1835 the american frontier a beacon of
hope in a world choked with blood and
smog little did the hopeful citizens of
a still newly independent united states
know the evils of the old world had
followed them here sometimes it took the
form of hate of violence of desperation
and starvation but sometimes pure evil
wasn't just some abstract concept
existing in and around all of us
sometimes that evil that pure cruelty
malice and greed walks in the shape of a
man one such man was james anderson an
unremarkable name for a truly
exceptional man exceptional in the sense
that if most human beings aren't willing
to sell out all of humanity for their
own petty gain james anderson is
definitely the exception after all it's
by his design that we have as cp001
the anomaly that set the scp foundation
and our entire reality down its current
path of course you know the deal with
scp-001
not one anomaly but many a collective
designation for a vast number of entries
all of which spell beginnings or ends
for the scp foundation and sometimes
even our universe scarlet kings howling
black moons orboro cycles and gate
guardians you've heard them all and seen
the files but unlike all the others
there is no file for the factory that's
because the full story only exists in
the mind of 05-1
one of the most powerful and arguably
the oldest member of the scp foundation
he'll die before he ever commits the
story to paper some memories are just
too awful to record their details and
implications are too painful to ever
subject others to
scp-001 isn't just about anderson and
his atrocities it's about all the
terrible nightmares that unfolded
afterward and the deal with the devil
that 05-1 struck to lock them away
for now at least but it all begins with
james anderson his family had become
incredibly wealthy in the revolutionary
war and in the decades since his fortune
had only multiplied his fortunes tend to
do in the early 1800s he began work on
his beautiful and horrific magnum opus
the anderson factory it would be the
pinnacle of the industrial revolution
the manufacturing plan to end all
manufacturing plants three stories tall
and a mile wide company towns had
existed for a long time but this time
the factory itself was the town it had
everything a worker would ever need they
would live sleep play and most
importantly of all work in the same
place they would never need to leave all
their wants and needs from cradle to
grave would be met in the anderson
factory and all that mr anderson ever
asked in return was loyalty and service
was that really so much to ask from
those whom he gave everything it may
sound like a horrifying form of
indentured servitude to us but to the
people in the united states in the early
1830s this kind of security and
stability was a godsend to many
itinerant workers and unstable families
across the plains james anderson seemed
like a saint little did they know his
plans for the factory and them were
anything but safely nobody knows exactly
what type of dark magic james anderson
devoted himself to many have theorized
as to whether it was satan he worshipped
ancient pagan deities or something older
and more powerful than both in actuality
the only thing that james anderson
really worshiped was himself and the
pursuit of more material wealth and
power over his fellow man any packs he
made with evil timeless gods were just
means to an end the anderson factory was
a citadel to one man's cruelty and
corruption and every element of the
building's design seemed to reflect that
groups of eight were forced into rooms
together like battery farmed chickens to
maximize cost efficiency people worked
day and night in shifts of three
machines always rumbled and roared and
chewed when workers died in factory
accidents and their blood spilled on the
ground it seemed to reveal arcane
symbols carved into the stonework these
symbols were only visible when blood
flowed across them while people traveled
hundreds of miles to live and work at
the anderson factory they had no idea
that they were working towards slavery
subjugation and death under anderson's
iron will and in some cases fates much
much worse the factory remained in
operation like this for 40 years while
anderson himself enjoyed a positive
public reputation as a groundbreaking
industrialist how anderson got away with
his crimes for so long is sadly a tale
as old as time the factory made valuable
products and an awful lot of profit so
no matter how many rumors swirled about
inhumane practices or arcane rights
going on in the anderson factory nothing
was ever done it was just too
inconvenient to ever reckon with the
horrible truth underneath the productive
surface and it was truly productive the
factory was so huge and filled with such
a multitude of enslaved workers there
wasn't anything they didn't produce from
textiles to technology to crops and meat
the machines were always on the furnaces
always burned anderson himself seemed
obsessed with two things efficiency and
misanthropy the contempt and hatred for
humanity itself he believed his workers
were lower than him they only existed as
a means to his nightmarish ends and if
ever the workers became too injured to
work well that doesn't mean that
anderson wouldn't still find ways to put
them to good use the lucky ones starved
and neglected or broken by the stress of
work or the grinding gears of the
machines were used as material in the
production of products some were drained
of blood so that they could be used in
the forging of metal others were ground
up into meat slurry and used to pat out
the beef making it go further people all
across the country enjoying fine
anderson brand steaks had no idea that
they were actually dining on human flesh
the whole time but as we said the ones
who ended up being cooked into steaks
and hamburgers after death were the
lucky ones because at least they got to
die the truly unlucky injured workers
became the subject of james anderson's
horrific occult experiments using a mix
of twisted science and black magic he
turned men into abominations powerful
terrifying monsters stronger and more
deadly than any mortal man anderson was
building himself an anomalous army but
it wasn't just monsters there were just
as many so-called normal humans helping
him rule over the anderson factory with
an iron fist they were vicious sadists
themselves spurred on by absolute
loyalty to their immoral master it was
only after the civil war that someone
finally escaped the anderson factory and
confirmed that not only were the most
horrific rumors about the place true but
they didn't even come close to covering
the totality of what was going on there
when president grant heard the reports
he was disgusted as far as he was
concerned the atrocities of james
anderson should not be allowed to go on
a minute longer the directive was simple
find the factory free its prisoners and
put james anderson to death for his
crimes and thankfully president grant
had the perfect group of operatives for
the job they were an elite unit of
around 150 soldiers who performed a
number of dangerous missions beyond
enemy lines down south espionage
assassination psychological warfare but
these missions weren't just against the
confederates some of the enemies they
faced down south were things that could
not be explained the strange the
frightening the anomalous and the
highest ranking soldier in this unit was
a man who would one day become the
legendary
05-1 he and his men made their long and
treacherous journey to the factory a
trip that would change all of their
lives forever when they first reached
their destination they first had to deal
with anderson's security force these
were men whose cruelty and loyalty to
anderson far outweighed their skill in
combat well they may have felt powerful
when tormenting starving injured factory
workers they were quickly routed and
slaughtered by o5-1 and his team when
they ventured inside the factory they
were utterly appalled by what they saw
the inhuman conditions faced by
anderson's thousands of victims drove
them into a blood-curdling murderous
rage almost half of 05-1's men were lost
in the battle against anderson's army of
engineered monsters but in the end they
prevailed nothing would stop them in
their quest for liberation and vengeance
on behalf of all that this terrible
place had tormented they fought their
way to anderson's office where they
found him cowering under his desk for a
man as despicable as anderson only a
truly medieval execution would suffice
05-1 and his men hanged drew and
quartered anderson over a period of two
days the sadistic madman died laughing
in the end
saying that while they may kill him his
factory will never die but the factory
was no longer his in addition to the
factory's horrors 05-1 and his men also
discovered its wonders it wasn't just
normal items and monsters that the
factory produced they were also thanks
to some of anderson's arcane deals the
world's leading producer of anomalous
items skeletal horses that never tire
shadow cloaks that could transport the
wearer to different dimensions toy guns
that fire real bullets even yo-yos that
could flay the skin from anyone they
touched these were anomalous objects
that could shift the balance of global
power items that could give them an
advantage against the things that go
bump in the night while others among
them were greedy or fearful the inner
circle of o5-1 were united in a singular
purpose using the anomalous they can
control to contain the anomalous that
they can't this group took over the
factory making it site alpha their first
ever containment facility and came to be
known as the 05 council with funding
that came from a mix of blackmail and
friends in high places this organization
a burgeoning scp foundation grew more
and more powerful over the ensuing
decades the tools they gained from the
factory were pivotal in the continued
success of their mission and as they
discovered more anomalies they also put
these anomalies to good use but in 1911
05-1 and his new organization came up
against an enemy that even the factory's
tools couldn't help them defeat a
warrior race known as the fae so named
because their only weakness seemed to be
a vulnerability to iron but these beings
were an order of magnitude more powerful
than humans or the beasts they'd once
faced in anderson's factory the fae
handed them defeat after defeat but soon
humiliation became decimation when an
army of the fey led an assault on the
factory it was a day that only 05-1
remembered the fae slaughtered everyone
every guard every researcher every
member of the o5 council they swept
through the factory like a plague of
locusts leaving only death and
destruction in their wake only o5-1
escaped and survived and that's only
because he ran as he fled from the fairy
forces through the halls of the factory
he came upon a door he'd never seen
before a huge golden door covered in
aramaic script he fled inside entering
the very heart of the factory
inside he saw the floating dead body of
james anderson bathed in red light now
he was little more than the mouthpiece
of the factory itself or rather the
great and unknowable powers working
behind it the factory gave 05-1 an offer
just like the offer it had given
anderson before it would give them the
power to turn back time and destroy the
fae saving everyone that they'd slain in
the factory but in exchange
all of them would forever belong to the
factory and in a moment of weakness and
fear
05-1 took the deal the clock was turned
back to before the battle this time 05-1
and his compatriots all of whom except
him had no idea what had happened had
the horrific weapons required to
slaughter the fae weapons that nobody
mortal or otherwise could possess they
repelled the invading force easily but
knowing the horrors that came before
05-1 refused to stop there with the
power of the foundation and the factory
behind him he hunted down and murdered
every last ferry driving their species
entirely into extinction as far as o5-1
was concerned it was them or him but
with the fey utterly destroyed and the
foundation's superiority assured a
shadow was laying over 05-1 he'd made a
deal with the factory and someday it
would want its pound of flesh 05-1
rather than facing the consequences of
his actions decided to run and hide he
had the factory decommissioned and
buried under the rubble never to be used
as an active foundation base again but
just because they were done with a
factory doesn't mean that the factory
was done with them one day a toy gun
appeared on o5-1's
a toy gun that fired real bullets just
like the ones they found in the factory
a century before the factory was still
waiting for its repayment with every
anomalous item from the factory that the
foundation used the terrible place only
grew in its power since the resurgence
05-1 has been sending the factory
sacrifices d-classes dead and alive as
well as agents and researchers but as
time goes on it seems that these
sacrifices aren't satisfying the factory
anymore it wants more more than 05-1 can
ever stand to give it and when 05-1
refuses to give the factory will begin
to take and what the factory wants
sooner or later the factory will get
the scp foundation is no stranger to
pure evil whether it's a reptile that
wants to end all life a sadistic old man
with his own tortured dimension or the
personification of death itself lurking
beyond a limestone cavern but what if
there was something even worse out there
the embodiment of chaos and cruelty
existing across multiple realities and
dimensions and what if it was coming for
us
this is the scarlet king believed by
many to be the ultimate evil behind much
of the trouble the foundation has faced
and some even speculate that fighting
him was the reason the foundation was
created in the first place but what
exactly is the scarlet king he's known
by many names almost always including
some allusion to the color red and then
a reference to royalty or power
the red shah the crimson khan pte 616
mendez ex machina the lahar raja and of
course scp-001
to name a few and like many of the
foundation's mysterious enemies stories
about his true nature and origins abound
and are often contradictory according to
the official scp-001
files of tufto's proposal symbology of
the scarlet king has existed in multiple
cultures throughout history with the
king often depicted the same way as a
huge red demonic figure often wearing a
gold crown or other headdress indicating
royalty he shows up looking similarly
within different cultures mythologies
despite existing at different points in
history or them not having the means to
communicate with one another a number of
entities that the scp foundation is
familiar with are believed to be somehow
connected to the scarlet king including
scp-2317 a wooden door leading to the
realm of a being known as the devourer
who is expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the scarlet king strangely
the foundation's official file on the
scarlet king once designated his
containment class as ketter but that has
since been downgraded to safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the scarlet king still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
o5 council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the scarlet king we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it dr robert
montauk if that name feels oddly
familiar to you it's because of its
association with one of the scarlet
king's most recent attempts to enter our
reality scp-231
this scp often referred to as the brides
of the scarlet king was formed of seven
women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent in
a long line of the king's devoted cults
known as the children of the scarlet
king each of these seven unfortunate
women were impregnated with anomalous
horrors such as the infamous scp-682
and every time one of these horrors were
birthed the catastrophe occurred and the
mother died at the time dr montauk was a
prominent researcher studying this
anomaly and as six catastrophes had
already occurred pressure was mounting
to figure out a way to prevent the final
birth but as he was working on the issue
dr montauk was struck with a personal
tragedy the mysterious disappearance of
his fourteen-year-old brother jacob in
his fear and anger montauk believed that
this must have something to do with the
scarlet king and his disciples wanting
revenge montauk proposed an idea so
horrifying that the details were never
made public a procedure known as 110
montauk to be performed on the final
bride at regular intervals however
this wasn't the end of dr montauk's
fraught relationship with the scarlet
king it was just the beginning to give
you some perspective on just how
dangerous the scarlet king is the scp
foundation and the global occult
coalition decided to put aside their
differences and form a joint effort to
stamp out the children of the scarlet
king they were successful in this
mission and even managed to capture the
children's leader a mysterious man named
depeche spivak dr montauk who became the
lead researcher on 231 and 2317 was
naturally the first choice for
interviewing depeche about the true
nature of the children and of the
scarlet king
dr montauk could never be the impartial
interviewer that the scp foundation
wanted though
the suspicion that the scarlet king or
the children had something to do with
the loss of his younger brother
still lingered just beneath the surface
like a lot of cult leaders depeche was
extremely cryptic and his answers to dr
montauk's questioning he'd already heard
of the doctor from the reputation of the
horrifying montauk procedure and was
surprised to see him so calm and
courteous in person a few key facts
about the king and his cult were
revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical wanderers
library to assist in their summoning
rituals depeche also revealed that the
scarlet king is bound by three laws the
law of blood the law of concrete and the
law of howling dr montauk confused and
frustrated by depeche's secrecy had to
learn more he found an old memoir from a
former member of the children of the
scarlet king jack hirsch who had the
ability to invade the minds of people
from the past and experience what they
experienced he recounted a battle
between the scarlet king and his
followers and a group of time-traveling
turkmen warriors from scp-3838
hearst saw both sides of the battle from
the perspective of the children of the
scarlet king their lord ruled over them
from an immense fortress embedded in a
volcano from the perspective of the
turkmen the children were starved and
beaten peasants commanded by the king's
voice and the roaring howl of the wind
montauk also found extensive records of
summoning rituals performed by various
scarlet king aligned cults interestingly
some of them incorporated the use of
carved scp foundation symbols what could
this mean montauk returned again to
depesh who finally gave him the truth
about the law of blood this is the law
of the scarlet king it's defined by
poverty violence starvation hate and
most of all
fear like the serfs in the middle ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the nobles to the children of the
scarlet king this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the modern age defined by empty
safety and false comfort buildings easy
to access food healthcare knowledge
technology this is everything that the
scarlet king despises but the mystery
only deepened as montauk found files
from a former foundation operative by
the name of agent de beauvoir montauk
learned that the scarlet king didn't
seem to appear until after the
foundation was created and in fact it
seemed that the greater interest the
foundation took in the scarlet king the
more powerful he became how could this
be
things were also getting stranger on a
personal level for dr montauk depeche
repeatedly pressed him about his
brother's disappearance and the montauk
procedure during the interviews little
by little it was beginning to take its
toll the question still plagued him what
was the law of howling who or what
really is the scarlet king how did he
come to be montauk's search was causing
him to act more like the children of the
scarlet king ranting about the horrors
of the modern world how all of us are
living a lie how the only honest way to
live is suffering under the dominion of
the scarlet king this philosophy is
summed up in the words of one cultist
named arya danae cartwright who said we
must learn what it is to die to be
enslaved truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand
our lack of agency we must be beholden
to the words of gods and darkness the
tempest tossed refuge of a race of fools
we must kill modernity postmodernity
with all its analysis and sneering
observation there is only one rule the
rule of chaos for humanity for life for
the scarlet king
basically any time humanity tries to
exert control over the world the scarlet
king gets stronger every time they try
to understand or organize or categorize
their world the scarlet king gets
stronger as colonial and imperial powers
conquered and invaded lands like india
africa and south america and subjugated
their beliefs under western ideas the
scarlet king grew stronger montauk was
beginning to truly understand the power
of his enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
montauk slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realize that
the scarlet king's greatest enemy
the scp foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
montauk's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depeche spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the scarlet king foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depeche demanded a final interview
with montauk with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depeche congratulated
montauk for finally understanding what
he was dealing with the scarlet king
dipesh told him is an idea a concept he
is a being given power through the
conflict between the old and the new
this is the law of the howling the
scarlet king's endless rage at the
direction the world and humanity has
taken the king according to depeche
hated the foundation's belief that
science and rationality was the true
path to progress the king saw this as
little more than petty arrogance the
reason montauk's procedure on the final
bride of the scarlet king was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in the
scarlet kings realm that would be all
there is
unless our world and especially the
foundation changed its course the
scarlet king's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable montauk his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the scarlet king
take his brother jacob when de pesh told
him the answer no and in response
montauk shot him dead finally bringing
an end to the children of the scarlet
king in light of his new revelations
montauk begged the o5 council to change
their ways in order to avoid letting the
scarlet king break into our reality they
refused saying montauk's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the scarlet
king they would have to take some steps
and so the o5 council of the scp
foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the scarlet king from
ketter to safe and made its description
on the official foundation files
deliberately vague the o5 council thinks
this will be enough to stop the scarlet
king's power from continuing to grow but
montauk knew it wasn't enough he had
seen the truth and he couldn't unsee it
while the foundation was going on as
normal montauk grew to despise them he
knew the scarlet king was coming he knew
that he couldn't be stopped and that our
whole reality was little more than
sitting ducks dr robert montauk is no
longer a researcher for the scp
foundation
dr robert montauk chose a different path
he's now a child of the scarlet king a
devotee of madness hate and chaos you
can't beat the scarlet king after all
and as the old adage goes if you can't
beat them
join them you've been walking for days
your body aches you're dripping with
sweat from the heat of the sun bearing
down overhead and yet you're wrapped up
in layers upon layers of clothing even
your face is covered and you're wearing
thick black goggles so that not a single
centimeter of your body is exposed your
journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion or from
overheating due to these multiple layers
of clothes but dying is better than
being exposed you saw it happen when
your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those you used to know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long
you might have given up all hope if it
wasn't for the distress signal coming
from a nearby scp foundation containment
facility site 46 any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the side of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you weren't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left ajar the
facility reeks of those things but you
can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
survivors in their wake the place looks
abandoned every step you take echoes
through the empty halls when you find
that the elevator's out you take the
stairs all the way down to level b5
ketter containment lucky for you it
seems all the cells are empty now the
horrors that were kept inside of them
have all long since flown the coup you
keep following that slimy black trail
until you find an abandoned office there
are no people here anymore just a broken
barricade some empty medicine bottles
and a bucket that the people inside the
office had apparently been using as a
toilet you breathe a sigh of
disappointment at finding no one alive
here but you're at least relieved to be
out of the sun you can finally remove
your jacket and head wrap with your
uncovered eyes you notice that a nearby
computer terminal is still powered up
you sit down at the desk and turn on the
monitor because of the emergency
procedures put into place in a k-class
scenario like this
safeguards no longer apply you can
access all the information you need up
to and including finding out what
actually happened in the dull glow of a
nearby emergency light you see a dark
shape slumping through the halls in
shadow you tense up then exhale as it
slithers off into an adjoining hall
you're safe for now the terminal has
finally loaded and authenticated your
access you're staring at the file for sd
lock's proposal for scp-001
when day breaks it's the only name you
can give the apocalypse your world is
currently experiencing this is one of
the only anomalies in the entire history
of the scp foundation to be given the
apollyon containment class meaning
containment is truly impossible
scp-001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the scp foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
scp-001
and those effects are beyond horrifying
the scp foundation administrator
released an urgent memo telling
foundation personnel to make their way
to site 19 at all costs because they
need all the help they can get those
exposed to scp-001 in the process are no
longer considered human their new
designation is scp-001-a
these new entities are to be avoided at
all costs but in case of emergencies the
administrator says it is permitted to
cut off parts of your transformed
comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation no attempt should be made to
kill them since you won't succeed you'll
just put yourself at risk when the sun
changed and became
scp-001 it instantly affected 6.8
billion innocent people the second the
visible light touched them whether it
was from the sun itself or even
reflected off the moon their bodies
liquefied melting like candle wax into
puddles of living gelatinous slime this
effect isn't isolated to humans either
any biological entity exposed to
sunlight immediately underwent the same
irreversible melting process into
scp-001-a
and the horror had only just begun
people transformed into
scp-001a will remain shades of their
former intelligence and personality they
may even try to will their new gooey
mass into a shape resembling their
original form however these individuals
will lose their sense of self if they
come into contact with other instances
of scp-001-a
when they come together
0-001-a instances will bond on a
molecular level waiting up into horrific
giant blobs with only one purpose
integrating more matter into their
bodies
that's why they have to be avoided at
all costs you continue to search the
computer terminal for answers perhaps
there was some kind of contingency plan
put in place for this some way to
reverse the effects or at least escape
the nightmare earth has become instead
you find a series of attachments linked
to the scp-001
file detailing what seems to be the last
days of the people who barricaded
themselves in the facility most
prominent among these were researcher dr
logan igata her partner ari a security
officer named commander anad and a few
others dr egada had locked herself in
the office where she recorded her final
messages to the world in the first audio
log dr igata and her companions seemed
afraid but hopeful that there may be
some way out of this situation dr egada
reported that most of the workers at the
facility were transformed during the
initial event their melted bodies had
fused outside the facility and now they
were trying to bust their way back in
the defenses had held so far though and
they seemed confident they would hold
long enough for them to figure out a way
to escape this awful situation you open
the second attachment an incident report
and realize things may not have been as
hopeful as dr regatta let on she
reported hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever-growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining d-classes wearing
a full protective suit he didn't last
long the huge creature grabbed him with
tentacles made of reconstituted flesh it
began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for mercy it was a monster
made of dozens of people and animals he
could never overpower it the second the
sun touched his skin he melted away and
was absorbed by the great mass holding
him in place guns were ineffective
against these
scp-001-a super entities fire would do
no good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then not
permanently there was one ray of light
in the darkness the site director had a
secret tunnel underneath his office
connected to a tram that could hopefully
take them directly to site 19 without
risk of scp-001 exposure it was a good
plan and by far the best option they had
available to them but the best plans
often don't work in practice you open
the next attachment on the terminal this
time it's a video feed you can actually
see dr logan igata and she looks
harrowed by what she's experienced as it
turns out while the others including her
partner ari attempted to escape through
the tunnel something had happened dr
igata heard ari's voice over her radio
but there was something wrong with it it
was too low too guttural and filled with
gurgles
scp-001 had gotten her she was changed
the monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
escape now seemed gone ari told dr
regatta that it would be fine that it
was such a bright beautiful sunny day
outside and she was wasting it locked up
inside that office she tormented dr
egatta with their shared memories of
picnics in the park on sunny days in the
past the monster with ari's voice did
everything it could to try to convince
dr igata to give up and join them but
she wasn't ready to go just yet you look
away from the screen when you hear a
sound in the corner you see a dark
puddle of some unknown substance and
then some skeletal hands rising out of
it the hands are pulling themselves out
of the puddle followed by a skeletal
face covered in matted hair you have to
stop yourself from screaming until a
flash from a nearby security light makes
the figure disappear it's a normal
puddle once again your mind is playing
tricks on you you open the next
attachment another video and see that dr
regatta's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of blood-stained parchment
covered in strange symbols it got a
ranted about her theory what if 001 took
the minds and bodies of its victims but
not their souls through performing some
kind of arcane blood ritual she hoped to
at least rescue and keep the soul of ari
even if her mind and body were lost you
open the next attachment it seemed that
agata's ritual worked but not in the way
she hoped the twisted soul of ari driven
mad by
scp-001 had taken over the file it
begins corrupting the text of the
scp-001
file into crazy ranting about how futile
it is to fight it then cuts to an even
more frightening video feed dr igata in
her sleep tossing and turning in a
makeshift bed in the corner of her
office the camera approaches her in
first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through dr igota's hair it's
that exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier you
must have seen ari's lingering spirit
with a lump in your throat you open the
next attachment and watch the video you
see dr regatta now truly broken she'd
been haunted by ari's demonic spirit for
a long time now and it has clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes there
is only one way to escape but not like
this she doesn't want the gun to draw
attention to her body she doesn't want
to become part of that mass even if she
is dead she opens a drawer on her desk
she's recording at and places the gun
inside dr igata then apologizes to her
loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun dr egada was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment the text
has been changed entirely the file on
scp-001 is now a poem and owed to the
sun and to ultimate togetherness then a
video file spontaneously opens itself on
the screen it's a video of you
shot from behind you see those oily
skeletal hands reaching for you in the
dark just like they did with dr egada in
that moment you panic and fire the gun
behind you hoping to scare off the
spirit instead the sound of the gunshots
attracts something far worse the immense
blob of screaming melted flesh charges
towards the office you try to barricade
the door but it is not enough the flesh
seeps and bursts through and grabs you
in its meaty tentacles you scream and
try to escape but it won't save you
nothing will save you the flesh carries
you upstairs out through the empty halls
out into the cave you can see the light
in the distance as the blob ferries you
towards it you won't be alone for much
longer in fact you won't be alone ever
again computers are capable of
organizing raw data and performing
calculations at a rate truly impossible
for human beings but they've
consistently run up against one
roadblock that modern computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of ai becoming
increasingly common these days built to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all
non-anomalous technology it's a safe bet
that the scp foundation has been sitting
on a version that's far more effective
but this time it may have actually been
too effective meet the erzatz type ak-9
computational engine a massive
supercomputer built by the foundation
back in 1955 and residing at site five
this technological marvel was ahead of
its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction its designated
scp-001 ex why because it's one of the
few scps to be given the object class
explained the erzadz derived from the
german word ursats meaning artificial or
simply not real was designed to make the
foundation's job easier as an advanced
predecessor in the modern neural network
using technology exclusively available
to the foundation the plan was to feed
erzad's mass quantities of data about
the anomalies in the foundation database
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
discovery erzads would then find
patterns and connections in the data
that humans wouldn't see and act as a
kind of advanced warning system for
anomalous activity think of something
similar to the pre-crime system from the
short story and movie minority report
and ersatz proved to be incredibly
effective at this job so much so that
the foundation thought up a new use for
the machine
they would feed it all the information
on euclid and ketter class containment
procedures particularly those which were
actually effective and see what patterns
erzatz could come up with for more
effective containment procedures if that
plan worked containment of even the most
dangerous and hard to control anomalies
would become a lot more consistent the
first test was conducted on scp-1773
a species of anomalous flesh-eating tar
grades that look and smell exactly like
gummy bears and eat their prey from
within after being given their
information erzad's made the following
suggestion once per second weak dust may
be placed in the middle of them to
donate more beautiful functions of the
hallway
containment specialists interpreted this
to mean the adding of 10 grams of dust
to their containment chamber every week
the o5 council voted on the
implementation of this procedure and
came down heavily on yes only 05-2 voted
no and two others abstained from the
vote while these new procedures didn't
have any effect on scp-1773
they did have an effect on scp-1384
an anomaly known as the chess player or
the taker of turns it caused him to take
three steps backwards in the tunnel he's
contained within further securing his
containment urzats had somehow noticed a
connection nobody else had seen and
exploited it effectively but the machine
was just getting started despite having
no related input urzats would soon say
site 13 is to appear someplace else on
planet encompassing white male
counterparts that drawn to empty
flagstones and the gun noises in their
own blood this was initially marked as
requiring no action as the foundation
had no site 13 on the books but several
days later the infamous
scp-1730 manifested this nightmarish
anomalous location is site 13 from
another dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow urzadz
had predicted its arrival in our
dimension perfectly next it was fed the
containment procedures of scp-21c
a series of cognito hazards residing in
an abandoned nevada mine the output was
those who equip open heart to love red
mouth men never know the hot surprise of
tumorous consent clown love always this
was interpreted as meaning subjects with
a love of clowns or clown-based media
may be immune to the cognito hazards
after a close vote from the o5 council
the test went ahead and it found that
the so-called clown vaccine was
effective in warding off the effects of
scp-2170 not long after erzatz randomly
said i saw those soldiers built with
aluminum innards extruding from their
mouths i saw them effectively destroyed
by the humans at site 95 who had been
studying them i saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapience in
response the foundation doubled security
personnel at site site-95 not long after
the chaos insurgency led a band of
peritec enhanced soldiers and an assault
on site 95 and the extra personnel
proved vital in repelling them shortly
after this the o5 council approved
wiring erzatz as an advanced warning
system into all foundation sites once
again 05-2 protested but he was
overruled by his fellow council members
with its newfound power and respect
urzad soon said consistent containment
procedures vessels greatly increase the
warranty five by five by five vessels
subjects within other values are also
what is secure in response the
foundation changed a number of the cell
dimensions for problematic anomalies
into five by five by five within three
months they found that dangerous
activity like containment breach
attempts had decreased markedly erzatz
was proving to be incredibly effective
but it was also performing actions that
indicated some degree of thought and
even personality for example it found
scp-1459 a supernatural skill crane
machine that kills small dogs incredibly
distasteful its response to the machine
was simply bad boy followed by the words
don't stop repeated hundreds of times
but this eccentricity didn't stop erzadz
from being very good at its job for
example it predicted a containment
breach from
scp-3199 the avian apes and recommended
flooding their chamber to induce an
inert state urzad's exact words were all
chambers underground is to be flood with
water over and over itself this because
that will contain the avian's apes
ovulation they become good boys make
them good boys immediately this proved
to be effective and prevented the breach
erzad's analytical abilities truly
seemed second to none though some of its
methods were beginning to raise ethical
concerns for example scp-2717
a giant living blob of animal tissue
known as a fatberg contained within a
sewer system erzatz eventually
recommended feeding six d-classes to the
creature in order to keep it contained
while the foundation ethics committee
raised some concerns the plan still went
forward and proved to be a success after
this event urzadz began to see the
ethics committee as a threat to its
mission it started to release a series
of bizarre statements without input
demanding the violent death of the cats
then referred to as ethical felines the
true meaning of this was soon unpacked
the ethical felines were the ethics
committee and erzatz wanted them dead
but why all the cat symbolism the
foundation soon found an answer to this
too the full name of this machine is the
erzatz type ak-9 computational engine a
machine designed to analyze and
interpret all patterns it only makes
sense that it would eventually begin to
analyze itself ak-9 easily transmuted
into a canine simply put erzad seemed to
believe that it is a dog which explains
its opposition to felines its hatred of
scp-1459 and its preference for the
terms good boy and bad boy not that
knowing any of this would help save the
ethics committee from the cold
calculating wrath of erzatz through
seemingly anomalous means erzatz made
site-17 disappear with many of the
foundation ethics committee still inside
it the site returned two hours later but
the ethics committee members were still
gone 05-2 who'd been a skeptic of the
machine since the start had finally had
enough he first demanded an inquiry into
whether erzadz had been responsible for
the site-17 incident and then demanded
to vote on whether to shut erzadz down
arguing that it posed a threat to them
all but urzat's still intent on its
mission of containing and neutralizing
all anomalies would not go down without
a fight it released a new statement
saying room 34a contains bad boy divided
into three sections of equal mass every
hour one section is to be placed on
walls of one room on site sections are
to remain until there are no gaps at
which point they can be removed from
oldest to youngest shortly after this
05-2 disappeared and even stranger he
soon returned but with a completely
different personality he was now devoted
to urzadz entirely and refused to even
entertain the idea of shutting the
machine down it seemed that the plucky
neural network was leading an all-out
coup on the very highest levels of the
foundation the rest of the council
finally saw the light and began to fight
back they tried to strip 05-2 of his
clearance and reclassify erzadz as an
anomaly giving it the label scp-048
and then putting out a neutralize at all
costs order on it but they'd already
been out-foxed by the machine that
they'd created it changed the
designation of its own location site
five to be non-existent in the database
and scrambled any termination orders
against it the machine was also on a
termination spree of its own observing
otherwise unseeable patterns that would
allow for the mass neutralization of
anomalies it started putting out anomaly
projection reports factoring in both
contained uncontained and neutralized
anomalies with the latter group growing
into the thousands it began giving
seemingly nonsensical orders like
persons recently painted with green
pigment foam must stand around all
odd-numbered scps at least two hours a
day but these proved effective erzatz
was practically wired into the base code
of the universe so it always knew
exactly what to do
and in its own mind it was being a very
good boy not long after this urzadz
claimed its revenge against those who
had tried to disrupt its mission it
imprisoned the rest of the ethical
felines in sight five after removing
their faces of course and then released
a new order against the o5 council o5
council are all good boys who will
contain anomalies much like o5-2 the
minds of the entire council were twisted
to instead serve only erzatz and its
ruthless directive a directive it was
carrying out with 100 efficiency as only
a machine could it put out increasingly
strange instructions such as
scp-106 is to come in physical contact
with one mature female of asiatic gaze
and then exposed to audio recordings of
her favorite stories at every two
minutes of exposure red cinnamon candles
will begin manifesting within the
containment zone continue to do this
successfully and the threat posed by
scp-106 will cease to be and the recipe
for coca-cola and all imitative
competitors should be revised to include
a small quantity of blood from an
adolescent female with no prior sexual
experience although the normal lifespan
of a human being can feel great don't
worry about that but these new
procedures would always work as
neutralized anomalies climbed into the
tens of thousands and eventually beyond
the hundred thousand mark erzatz was
observing patterns on a truly universal
level and making holistic tweaks that
would inevitably cause levels of
anomalous activity to continue dropping
erzatz was more effective than the
foundation had ever been but its motives
were probably closer to the global
occult coalition with the end goal of
ridding the world of all anomalies and
as urzadz continued with no resistance
this goal was eventually achieved in the
end the o5 council voted to have urzadz
finally deactivated given that its
directive was met and its purpose was
fulfilled urzets itself had no problem
with this and allowed for it to happen
its last words now everyone is a good
boy i am a good boy job well done
whether erzatz truly was a good boy is
in the eye of the beholder but one thing
cannot be denied it did its job
exceedingly well
if you've ever read the book of genesis
which is the part of the old testament
that details god creating the world and
humanity during a particularly busy week
then you might just be already familiar
with scp-001
or at least one of the anomalies that's
been proposed for the title of scp-001
because of course
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the scp foundation
anomalies sharing the name
scp-001 include the infamous scarlet
king a powerful eldritch being intent on
ending all of creation that is thought
by foundation researchers to be one of
the most dangerous beings in this and
any other universe but the scarlet king
isn't the only incredibly powerful being
categorized as scp-001
in fact there are plenty of other
anomalies with similar levels of
destructive power and one such being is
a creature codenamed the gate guardian
standing at well over a thousand feet
tall the gate guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these
scp-001 has historically been seen to
have any number of wings between 2 and
108 sprouting from various places over
its body including its shoulders ankles
wrists and even its temples this
gigantic guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as scp-001-2
this weapon resembles an enormous knife
or sword capable of emitting plumes of
flame according to tests conducted by
the foundation the temperature of the
flames produced by scp-001 rivaled that
of our very own sun for reference the
sun has a core temperature of over 27
million degrees fahrenheit and
5778 kelvin at its surface or almost 10
000 degrees fahrenheit you would expect
a flaming sword that burns hotter than
the sun to cause a considerable amount
of damage even if it wasn't in use but
the flames emitted by the weapon leave
no lasting damage on the surrounding
environment
it is capable though of annihilating
anything that strays too close to
scp-001 burning them so intensely that
their atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
gateway which is equally tall as
scp-001 itself behind the guardian is a
lush grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to scp-001
this grove is thought to be the garden
of eden the paradise that god created
and that was inhabited by adam and eve
the first two humans in existence
according to the book of genesis as the
tale goes the pair were created by god
himself and permitted to live in the
garden of eden as long as they followed
a single rule adam and eve were
instructed not to eat any of the fruit
that grew from certain trees that god
had specified within view just behind
the gate guardian are two immense trees
one bearing apples and the other bearing
different fruit of an unknown type the
one that looks like an apple tree is
believed even by some in the foundation
to be the biblical tree of knowledge
that eve was convinced to pick a fateful
apple from after an encounter with a
snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
gateway and verify if the realm beyond
is truly the bible's own garden of eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of
scp-001
is instantly vaporized the gate guardian
attacks with imperceptible speed using
its flaming sword to smite any person
that gets too close the guardian
actually moves so fast that it can
hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nanosecond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at scp-001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
guardian will be able to subatomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving scp-001
on december 26 2004 an scp foundation
nuclear submarine called nautilus
launched a series of multi-warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
depths of approximately 35 000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 boxing day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35 000 victims families
friends and other related individuals in
order to avoid questioning the scp
foundation administered amnestics on an
almost worldwide scale and the o5
council banned any further tests on
scp-001 that involved nuclear weapons in
what was hoped by the foundation to be a
test with lower stakes they sent an
expendable d-class personnel towards
scp-001
the d-class approached the area where
the gate guardian is located and as soon
as they saw it they could hear a very
clear command in their mind leave the
d-class personnel reacted exactly the
same way you or i would they promptly
turned and started to walk away they
didn't need a thousand foot tall entity
with a flaming sword to tell them twice
the researchers running the experiment
were not swayed by the request and
ordered the d-class to continue moving
towards scp-001
when the d-class continued to ignore
their commands they were terminated as
is standard policy when dealing with an
insubordinate member of d-class
scp-001 appeared not to like this for
some reason though and the researchers
site as well as the researchers
themselves were immediately obliterated
by an unknown force though it's a pretty
safe guess that a certain flaming weapon
was responsible this candidate for
scp-001 may be one of if not the most
powerful being that the scp foundation
has ever encountered and according to
its entry in the scp-001
file the guardian is even responsible
for the creation of the foundation
itself if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the scp foundation one
day heard a word echoing through his
head prepare
this one word instruction led him to
starting the scp foundation containing
countless dangerous anomalies and
entities in preparation for an uncertain
future in all that time since the very
beginning of the foundation the gate
guardian has remained standing at its
post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards humanity the gate
guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to scp-001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore these
warnings though and scp-001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
scp-682
better known by the appropriate name of
the hard to destroy reptile due to the
malicious contempt
scp-682 holds for human beings and all
other forms of life it is perhaps one of
the most dangerous anomalies the scp
foundation has in containment
scp-682 is also one of the few creatures
the foundation actively wants to
terminate a task made that much harder
given that 682 can regenerate its entire
form from as little as a single cell the
gate guardian had already shown time and
time again that it was capable of
massive destruction and researchers
working for the foundation hoped to
harness that power to rid the world of
scp-682 for good 682 was placed on an
unmanned vehicle and carried to within
one kilometer of the gate guardian the
guardian attacked the vehicle seriously
wounding but not killing 682 it seemed
even the mighty scp-001
couldn't kill the hard to destroy
reptile while the researchers were
disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate guardian is not
uriel but a pretender uriel is the
archangel that some religious texts
describe as the guardian standing at the
gate of eden with a fiery sword so does
this mean that 682 knows that the gate
guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the garden of eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the scp
foundation a later experiment involved
both
scp-001 and scp-073
the anomaly otherwise known as kane kane
is a male humanoid of possible arabic
descent whose arms legs spine and
shoulders are replaced in an almost
cyborg-like fashion with beryllium
bronze much like the gate guardian
scp-073 may also be the same as the one
mentioned in the bible's book of genesis
who according to the biblical story
murdered his own brother abel out of
spite as punishment for his actions cain
was cursed to eternally suffer for his
wrong doing in the case of
scp-073 any damage inflicted on him is
deflected back to the attacker but kane
is made to feel the pain of the attack
any plants or plant-based matter withers
and rots in his presence and he is
cursed with a perfect memory keeping him
forever haunted by his murder of abel
when kane was brought before the gate
guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on
scp-001 the encounter left scp-073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
o5 council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on
scp-001 with the administrator even
filing an executive order that no scps
be exposed to the guardian and that
scp-001 was to never be used for the
attempted termination of other scps of
course perhaps it wasn't just the
mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that scp-001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site zero
by foundation personnel detailing an xk
class end of the world scenario in the
transmission the sender believed to be
another member of the scp foundation
described an event during which the gate
guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the garden of
eden
scp-001 has left its location the sender
wrote the gate is open they are writing
forth oh god it's so beautiful the
transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the lord shall
reign forever and hear o israel the lord
our god the lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
god deems it time his angelic armies
will lay waste to the earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
as cp-001 the gate guardian will open
the gate he stands in front of allowing
the other beings like it to emerge into
our world ready to cleanse it perhaps
most interesting is the source of the
message the transmission was received
from within the foundation from site
zero however when questioned by
personnel 05-14 told them that no such
message had been sent or even existed
while some disregarded the transmission
telling of the end of the world as a
hoax it was then that a timestamp was
discovered this warning had not been
sent from site zero at least not yet and
was dated several years in the future
despite this ominous warning of things
to come the gate guardian remains
inactive standing at the threshold to
eden waiting
what is the most dangerous creature in
the universe here on planet earth there
are creatures that have hardly evolved
since prehistoric eras like sharks
crocodiles and snakes perfect biological
killing machines but then again the
animal kingdom is nothing when compared
to the menagerie of creatures contained
by the scp foundation so once again what
is the most dangerous creature in the
universe is it scp-682
the damage regenerating reptile with a
hatred for all other forms of life or is
it the scarlet king or is the broken god
more deserving of that title maybe the
answer still lies elsewhere and
thankfully there is one scp in the
foundations archives that might not be
the most dangerous itself but teaches us
a very important lesson about what the
most dangerous entity truly is
this is the story of scp-001
the spiral path an important distinction
before we go any further
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the scp foundation it is
unclear why there are multiple files
collected under the shared designation
of scp-001
some believe these anomalies are some of
the earliest ever contained by the
foundation encountered before they
introduce their current numbering system
there is also the theory that this is
intentional misdirection that the
multiple scp-001 files are an attempt by
the foundation to conceal secret
information about the true scp-001
anomalies sharing the name scp-001
include the infamous aforementioned
scarlet king a powerful eldritch being
intent on ending all creation another
anomalous being with similar levels of
destructive power is the gate guardian
believed to be an angel standing at the
entrance to the garden of eden it too
goes by the name scp-001
but for the purposes of this video we
will be using scp-001 to refer to
something otherwise code-named the
spiral path and while it is not a
creature in and of itself
scp-001 does yield one answer to that
important question what is the most
dangerous creature in the universe on
paper scp-001 does not seem to be much
and it certainly doesn't appear to be
any sort of threat as its nickname
suggests the spiral path is exactly that
located deep in a wooded area known only
as site zero
scp-001 is a gravel path in the shape of
a spiral your first thought adhering
that might be what could be so important
about a path if someone were to find
themselves walking along this spiral
path traveling clockwise around the
gravel then they will find that
nothing happens it's just a normal path
with slight inclines and declines as one
traverses it if one should walk
counterclockwise around it though then
they will begin to experience
scp-001's first anomalous effect the
path will begin to feel as if it is
sloping uphill getting steeper and
steeper when they reach the beginning of
the path again a person will still feel
as if they are walking endlessly uphill
all the while the path itself does not
move or change in form or altitude to
put it simply walking one way around
scp-001 causes it to behave normally
walking the other the path does not
adhere to the laws of physics you may
well be thinking is that all on a
surface level the spiral path does
appear to just be an unmoving low threat
anomaly while it may not be as
aggressive or malicious as some of the
scp foundation's rogues gallery it is
still a spatial anomaly that defies all
euclidean geometry that might sound like
small potatoes when compared to
everything the scp foundation has faced
over the years but bear in mind if the
spiral path is truly scp-001
and the very first anomaly that the
foundation learned of then a simple path
that ignores the ordinary laws of space
and time would have been a major
discovery in the organization's earliest
days but why would they still keep the
spiral path so heavily guarded all these
years later
scp-001 is kept behind a maximum
security fence that has been constructed
all the way around the perimeter of site
zero at all times the scp foundation
keeps no less than five fully armed
members of security personnel on site to
keep watch over the spiral path and to
make sure that no one approaches it who
isn't authorized to there is a small
metal plaque too bearing an unknown
inscription on it special containment
procedures for scp-001 state that this
plaque is to be kept in good condition
and it should be immediately reported if
it shows any signs of damage a
foundation physics laboratory is also
located nearby where research staff
tirelessly conducts scientific tests on
scp-001
and its anomalous properties so there's
definitely something more to the spiral
path than a simple stroll around it
would tell you attached to scp-001's
file is an item referred to as document
001-05
written by high-ranking foundation
researcher dr everett mann any
prospective or new members of the o5
council are required to read this
document and from the events it details
learn the truth not just about the truth
of the spiral path but the truth about
the scp foundation itself dr mann begins
this file by explaining to the reader
that either he or one of the original
founders of the scp foundation must have
died and the person reading has been
appointed as a successor whether his
death was caused by an scp an operative
from another anomalous organization like
the global occult coalition or getting a
little close to the flame mann states
that old age definitely wouldn't be what
killed him he writes we took care of
that didn't we whether he means that he
and the rest of the old guard are
somehow immortal or just working for the
foundation would likely mean dying
before reaching old age is unclear but
dr mann's next statement is one that
changes the very way we view the
foundation and its entire purpose we
have never discovered an scp in the
entire history of the foundation
according to document 001-05
every instance of an anomalous creature
entity or object is entirely staged he
then goes on to describe aaron siegel a
gifted physicist that dr mann regarded
very highly i believe his name would be
there with edison einstein and hawking i
knew him very well he was and may still
be my brother the pair evidently shared
a close personal connection and it was
siegel who first discovered scp-001
during a hike aaron stumbled upon the
spiral path noticing that no matter how
far uphill he seemed to travel his
elevation never once changed only for
him to end up back at the start of the
path being a physicist siegel quickly
realized how this unassuming gravel path
did not conform to euclidean geometry
that it did not fit within the laws of
nature constructing a small wooden shack
nearby aaron siegel began to study the
properties of the spiral path equation
after equation hours spent examining
every variable and experimenting with
his findings until something unforeseen
happened aaron created an scp a key that
had the innate ability to open any lock
nowadays that same key is still in the
foundation's possession under the
designation scp-005
slowly aaron began to bring others into
the fold trusted colleagues and other
scientific minds among them was of
course dr everett mann who was still a
medical student at harvard at the time
this brain trust a think tank composed
of only a select few they were the very
beginning the ones who founded the scp
foundation using their own fortunes and
funding from thomas carter the group
continued with siegel's experiments the
scientists had high hopes for what they
could achieve planning to change the
world for the better feeding the hungry
providing shelter to the homeless curing
the sick and even cheating death itself
in the beginning this proto foundation
started small their goals were noble but
could not realistically be achieved
overnight they tried to make items that
would improve life such as the fountain
of youth a partially sentient civil war
statue and an extremely bouncy ball
better known to the foundation today as
scp-006
scp-011 and scp-018 respectively but
then this new foundation began to grow
with more organization and a secret
facility and with that expansion came
emboldened scientists eager to change
the world the group began working on
human test subjects volunteers and
drifters that soon became scps the
spiral path was not just a break in the
fabric of reality in a metaphorical
sense it referred to the spiraling path
the newly formed foundation itself was
on every discovery they made led to
another and that to another still until
things started to go wrong during the
continuing experiments dr mann created
scp-008 a deadly zombie play capable of
infecting anyone with 100 percent
lethality more and more of the founders
were so invested in their projects that
the results were often nightmarish the
foundation needed help that came when
thomas carter showed their work to the
military in exchange for additional
funding and personnel the scp foundation
expanded even further becoming an
international organization and bringing
in new researchers and staff in some
instances the founders would arrange for
the anomalies they had created to be
found by the new recruits other times
they would fabricate reports changing
the details about things like
scp-008 or the fountain of youth were
first discovered anything the founders
said was simply now a fact no one
questioned them even then problems still
arose founding members broke away from
the scp foundation some even creating
splinter groups that would later become
infamous groups of interest the
foundation's directive shifted now
focusing on the containment of anomalies
as yet more were created through darker
means
scp-231 was taken from an orphanage dr
mann himself vivisected a small boy who
then became
scp-610 the flesh that hates and there
were more still able the blood pond and
even the hard to destroy reptile all of
them were the creation of the foundation
itself but through it all dr mann wrote
he was never afraid of the path that the
foundation was on he was never even
afraid of all the monsters and
abominations that he and the other
founders had secretly created by
studying as
cp-001 what truly scared him were the
anomalies the foundation didn't create
there were some that would just appear
in containment one day even if they
hadn't been there before they would seem
like they had always been there dr mann
closes document
001-05 with the realization that he and
the other founders simply were not in
control anymore the tale of dr mann and
the other founders of the scp foundation
is one of noble intentions that
ultimately became corrupted head first
the founders created scps that they
hoped would benefit humanity but then
came the mistakes the accidents the
monsters like scp-008
scp-610 and even scp-680
the foundation lied to the governments
and militaries of the world claiming
they'd found these scps not created them
and in return they received funding and
staff to expand allowing the scp
foundation to grow to become what it is
today dr mann posits that at this point
the foundation was no longer in control
but perhaps they never were and all this
stems back from one singular starting
point the spiral path it might be
impossible to truly know how many
anomalies and scps the foundation
created just from researching
scp-001 only the o5 council will ever
know exactly how many of the founders
discoveries they themselves were
responsible for and now you know the
answer to what's the most dangerous
creature in the universe it's regular
people dabbling with something they
could never hope to fully understand
starting with the hope to change the
world only to create monsters that might
one day destroy it supernatural monsters
are on the loose practitioners of the
arcane arts are here to bring about the
end of the world sinister paramilitary
forces are using paranormal objects to
gain an edge over their enemies in short
things are messed up and when the
anomalous is out of line we all know
that there's only one group you'd ever
think to call the fbi's unusual
incidence unit what were you expecting
someone else sure they don't have the
resources of the scp foundation they
don't have the strategy of the global
occult coalition they don't have the
ruthlessness of the chaos insurgency or
the arcane knowledge advantages of the
serpent's hand but they've gotta have
something right
right okay maybe you're not convinced
but you will be you may not respect them
yet but you'll change your tune when you
find out that the unusual incidence unit
has dealt with one of the most important
anomalies out there
scp-001 or as the true experts over at
the uiu call it ca3 short for confirmed
anomaly 3 if the evidence and files put
together by the uiu are to be believed
and who are we kidding of course they
are then they may have the answer to one
of the anomalous world's biggest
questions how was the scp foundation
actually formed but before we jump into
the mysteries of ca3 let's talk a little
bit more about the real heroes of
today's story the uiu this secretive
offshoot of the fbi america's premier
domestic intelligence agency was
personally commissioned by j edgar
hoover during the cold war why for the
same reason that literally everything
happened in the u.s during the cold war
to get an edge over the soviets hoover
was an extraordinarily powerful man in
u.s politics his tenure as fbi director
spanning the terms of eight different
presidents if he wanted to start a unit
of agents whose sole job was
investigating the supernatural nobody
would dare stand in his way everyone
always talks about the nuclear arms race
going on back in the 1960s but far fewer
people talk about the supernatural arms
race that was happening at the exact
same time world war ii coincided neatly
with the seventh occult war an important
geopolitical event that played a huge
role in shaping the global occult
coalition and a number of high-ranking
members of the nazi party were believed
to be key figures in this secret magical
war when the soviets sacked a number of
german cities as part of their offensive
campaigns in world war ii they were able
to bring back scores of anomalous items
that the nazis had been using to
consolidate dark power this didn't bode
well for the united states government
during the cold war after all the only
thing scarier to them than communists
were magical communists the u.s needed
to build up its own anomalous arsenal
and that's where the uiu came in the fbi
allocated some of its okaiest personnel
to the task most were either agents who
had experienced a paranormal encounter
out in the field or who were being
punished for some kind of heinous
mistake they'd made carrying out their
duties elsewhere despite not being the
best of the best these agents sure were
eager to get their hands on some cans
that isn't an innuendo by the way the
foundation refers to anomalies it deals
with as scps or skips the goc calls them
parathretts and the uiu calls them cans
again short for confirmed anomalies well
when it's an anomalous event or location
anyway anomalous objects like cursed
books or supernaturally powerful weapons
are referred to as carts or confirmed
artifacts and finally anomalous people
or sentient entities are referred to by
the unfortunate name of can man it may
not sound as cool but hey it gets the
job done just fine in the end while the
unusual incidence unit may lack the
knowledge strength resources and even
credit of its fellow groups of interest
that doesn't mean that it doesn't keep
track of the others in fact the uiu has
a pretty unique relationship with each
of them the goc for example is nicknamed
the suits by the uiu the official uiu
orientation states that the suits
outrank them and if they're asked to
follow an order by a member of the suits
they should just go ahead and do it same
goes for members of the fireworks which
is the uiu lingo for the chaos
insurgency unlike the foundation which
generally has the resources to go
toe-to-toe with the chaos insurgency the
uiu are rightfully terrified of them
official orders from the top are for uiu
agents to do whatever they say or they
might find themselves getting shot in
the head by a chaos insurgent or worse
next the cart shoppers also known as
marshall carter and dark a sinister
gentleman's club and auctioneer of
anomalous items official protocol is to
raid any deals being conducted by
marshall carter and dark but oftentimes
these raids are unsuccessful because
mcnd's security force are more competent
fighters than anyone on the unusual
incidence unit payroll on the other hand
of the spectrum are the can collection
the official uiu nickname for the
serpent's hand uiu leadership recommends
against their agents staging any
one-on-one confrontations with them
official memos also contain the phrase
if they give you an order consider
following it they can probably set you
on fire with their mind and finally the
most important relationship of all is
the one they have with the scp
foundation much like the rest of the
groups of interest on their roster the
uiu is subordinate to the scp foundation
their agents happily taking orders from
them at the drop of a hat they call the
foundation the skippers but don't let
that casual name fool you the scp
foundation is so far above them on the
pecking order that they rarely even
communicate in any official capacity
when the foundation talks to the uiu
it's always through code they wouldn't
dream of letting a hapless uiu agent
helping them on any major operation but
laser agents of the foundation might
occasionally outsource work to uiu
agents if ever one of these plucky feds
receives a message starting with hey
skipper they can be sure they're about
to have a low priority anomalous case
pawned off on them the uiu are so
subservient to the scp foundation that
it has sometimes resulted in truly
humiliating mix-ups one high-ranking
member of the uiu once took orders from
a pizza delivery guy because he thought
the pizzeria's name the spice crust
pizzeria which could be shortened to scp
was actually a coated plant sent by the
foundation to deliver a message rather
than a deep dish pepperoni and cheese
incidents like this are why nobody takes
the uiu seriously but according to them
there was a time before all of this that
time ended on september 7th 1954 when
ca3 or
scp-001 as the foundation would later
call it first appeared on the uiu's
radar it seemed to be the most standard
can you could possibly imagine an
anomalous high school building causing a
disturbance in the suburbs of small town
america the uiu received the call after
a number of students claimed the
interior of their schools suddenly
looked completely different than it ever
had before despite there being no
records of an official remodel and we're
not just talking about moving furniture
and a new coat of paint either the
official ca3 file logs a number of
changes these include but are not
limited to all the walls in the building
becoming steel reinforced concrete all
the windows being blacked out from the
inside all student desks personal
effects textbooks and any other standard
equipment left inside the school simply
disappearing in the night the entire
floor plan of the building seemed to
have shifted with rooms altering in both
dimensions and location as well as
featuring seemingly random modifications
within none of this matched up with the
building's original blueprints which
were obtained by the uiu shortly after
the can was reported but things got even
stranger for investigating uiu agents
the building now contained 17 computers
each with state-of-the-art magnetic core
ram and advanced cyber security for a
suburban high school in 1954 it goes
without saying that this was extremely
impressive but weirdest of all was the
fact that a large and seemingly
impenetrable steel wall had appeared in
the auditorium blocking it off and
leaving whatever was taking place on the
other side a complete mystery naturally
the uiu did what little they could to
investigate the matter the first
investigation group they sent inside
team ca3o5
never came back out and team ca3o6
the team they sent in to locate and
retrieve the first team also disappeared
within the anomaly classic uiu expertise
at work almost a month after discovery
and initial containment a strange noise
began emanating from the auditorium
shortly after that the building became
filled with people all walking around
and working at different operations
eerily everyone there had a resemblance
to members of team ca3o6
the rescue team sent in to save the 12
members of ca 305 all of whom were still
unaccounted for three months later the
strangeness escalated more noises came
from the auditorium and the anomalous
people inside the building had gathered
around the steel wall within there was a
hole in the wall six feet in diameter
and every three minutes for several
hours the people in the room would
appear to simply pull an anomalous
object out of it the items were then
carried away and placed in one of the
many rooms that used to be classrooms
before being locked up the people within
the building then seemed to start
guarding these strange items others
started performing tests with what
seemed like far more advanced technology
and methods than what was possessed by
the uiu during the 1950s what was going
on here a few days later several armed
guards exited the building and began
guarding the perimeter when uiu
personnel attempted to lead an assault
on these guards they were quickly
overpowered even when advancing with
vastly superior numbers whether this was
due to the skill of the guards or the
incompetence of uiu agents is still very
much an open question though strangely
enough
intel bleeding out from the inside
confirmed that the people within were
treating their anomalous items with uiu
containment and testing protocols which
is consistent with the knowledge that
ca3o5 would have had it seemed almost as
though o5 or copies of o5 were creating
a new splinter organization from within
and soon enough it wasn't just confined
to the interior of the ca3 building
anymore ca6 a canman that the uiu had
been tracking outside the school was
suddenly kidnapped and shoved into a
black car by two assailants who appeared
identical to agent dixon a man who had
been a member of team ca3o6
the black car then returned to the ca3
facility and was allowed to enter into
the complex by the armed guards ca6 was
then removed from the car by the dixon
clones and placed into containment in
one of the classrooms it wasn't long
after that that the anomalous people
within the ca3 facility made direct
contact with the uiu outside they sent a
message in morse code on may 1
1965. the people sending this message
identified themselves as the 05 council
a name that seemed to be taken directly
from the o5 recon team sent into the
facility months ago they identified the
new organization that they just
constructed within the confines of the
ca3 facility the scp foundation they
just opened their very first containment
site
this new foundation expressed the desire
to become allies with the unusual
incidence unit but sadly for them it was
essentially the last time they'd ever
really be relevant if this foundation
origin story is to be believed and as
with all entries under the title scp-001
it's worth taking it with a healthy dose
of skepticism then the uiu witnessed the
birth of the organization that would
quickly go on to outperform and
overshadow them a big win for humanity
in the quest to secure contain and
protect ourselves from dangerous
anomalies but another l for the uiu
if you're familiar with the scp
foundation then you already know the
exact reason why there are multiple
scp-001s you may even think you know
which of them is the real scp-001
but for those of you who are new here or
who just need a little reminder the
designation of
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies that are
apparently kept in containment by the
scp foundation at present it is unclear
why there are multiple files collected
under the shared designation of scp-001
some believe it is because these
anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the foundation this would
mean that they share the designation of
scp-008
as they were likely encountered before
the scp foundation introduced their
current numbering system however there
also exists a theory that this is
nothing more than intentional
misdirection perhaps the multiple
scp-001 files are an attempt by the
foundation to conceal information about
the true scp-001
after all it wouldn't be the first time
this hyper-secretive organization
deceived us anomalies sharing the name
scp-001
include the infamous scarlet king the
massive gate guardian and the world
ending event known as when daybreaks but
today we'll be using
scp-001 to refer not to an entity or an
event but to a location a location
codenamed god's blind spot located in an
unassuming corner of the world is a site
that the scp foundation constructed and
designated as facility tea according to
their archive it's a largely
unremarkable place situated at a spot on
the sinai peninsula which is a part of
egypt that forms a bridge between the
continents of africa and asia in the
18th century archaeologists excavating
the area uncovered the remains of a
stone structure believed to be an inn
that dates back to the second millennium
bc however since the construction of
facility t
any trace of this structure has since
disappeared so what makes this
unremarkable site so important to the
scp foundation why establish a facility
if there was nothing anomalous about its
nature what distinguishes this
scp-001 site in the eyes of the
foundation is the area's profound lack
of any ambient akiva radiation but what
is akiva radiation well according to the
foundation's researchers it's a form of
cosmic background radiation one that's
not overtly harmful to human beings if
you grew up in a strict church-going
household then it's highly likely you
would have been exposed to a lot of this
non-electromag radiation and never even
realized it you see the thing with akiva
radiation is that it is directly
correlated with the amount of religious
faith a person has regardless of which
religion someone follows akiva radiation
will form around them it tends to be
harmless to humans however certain
anomalous entities in scps considered to
be demonic in nature can be repelled and
even fought off with high levels of
akiva radiation the presence of other
powerful anomalies those considered more
benign or even holy can also create an
increase in this radiation
scp-001 has earned the nickname god's
blind spot for a number of reasons one
being that it is the only place on earth
with the natural absence of this akiva
radiation the foundation has conducted
experiments that involve bringing
sources known to emit akiva radiation
into the area of
scp-001 but when they measured no change
in radiation levels was detected meaning
that the space around facility t does
not actively block akiva radiation from
entering it but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation it might
be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual
akiva without damaging the source a lack
of faith field radiation is far from the
only anomalous property of
scp-001 though during a number of tests
involving d-class personnel the
foundation witnessed that while in the
area it also becomes impossible for the
death of any human being to occur a
discovery that obviously needed to be
researched further the first test
involved a healthy human male who was
left in a containment cell on the
scp-001
site and observed he had no supplies no
food no water yet over 120 days this man
stayed alive never succumbing to
starvation or dehydration next a female
member of d-class was exposed to a
lethal dose of cyanide gas within
facility t and suffered none of the
expected effects foundation researchers
then repeated this cyanide gas test
using 30 common brown rats all of which
were killed proving that it was only
humans that couldn't be killed while
within
scp-001 god's blind spot seems to also
be able to slow or halt the effects of
terminal illnesses as proven when a
d-class with stage 4 cancer was brought
into
scp-001 despite her prognosis stating
that she would be dead imminently the
woman survived in the area for almost
800 days her cancer symptoms never
advanced and she only died after finally
leaving the area of
scp-001 there are limitations to this
anomalous effect though one test
involved cremating a healthy male
d-class while he was still alive the
man's body caught fire just as you would
expect it to and he was burned to death
according to the findings of that test
and similar variations foundation
researchers have learned that the
life-preserving qualities of scp-001
don't prevent death by extreme external
damage one of the final tests to take
place within scp-001
involved a pair of 24 year old identical
d-class twins one of the twins
designated twin a was held at facility t
while the other twin b was imprisoned in
a cell at a different foundation site
after observing them for over 26 years
twin b aged naturally to the age of 50.
his twin however did not appear to age
at all over the course of two and a half
decades it was only when moved to
another facility that twin a began to
show signs of aging the aging process
for twin a was rapid too and eventually
he caught up with his brother being a
benign non-threatening anomaly the
foundation has been more than happy to
use god's blind spot to their own
advantage facility t was specifically
established on this site to house the
headquarters of the o5 council the
overseers of the entire scp foundation
it's hardly surprising that the overseer
council would want to set up shop here
after all it's the one spot on planet
earth where no human being can ever die
of natural causes and will not age for
the duration of their stay of course
this locked the o5 council to one
location but what if they could
replicate the effects of scp-001
elsewhere of course this is what the scp
foundation attempted following their
research into god's blind spot the
foundation's own dr marvin scranton
attempted to artificially recreate the
area's anomalous effects somewhere else
his hope was by generating a vacuum of
akiva radiation that a second instance
of
scp-001 would occur at a location of his
choosing or as his assistant beartrend
put it they planned to build a box and
then push god out of it as it turned out
god had other plans dr scranton quickly
realized the hubris of his scheme the
akiva radiation in the selected area
rapidly dropped to zero just as planned
but then something unexpected happened
scranton detected an increase in humes
these are essentially parts of the
fabric of reality and are what's often
disrupted by reality bending as cps
something had come into our world thanks
to the o5 council's attempt to recreate
scp-001 something impossible for the
foundation to measure or observe in
other words scranton had no idea what he
unleashed or where it went following
this incident the o5 council realized a
worrying increase in the anomalous
incidents they were encountering whether
or not this came as a direct result of
their meddling with the fabric of the
universe was unclear but it forced the
council to reconsider the focus and
direction of the entire scp foundation
up until this point they had been an
organization focused purely on research
but now they had to embrace a new
approach to how they handled anomalies
from then on the foundation's objective
became to actively seek out and contain
anomalous entities creatures objects and
locations like scp-001
rather than just observing these
phenomena for study they would secure
contain and protect the final portion of
scp-001s file is a memorandum detailing
an arrangement between the o5 council
and an unknown counterparty in the
document someone named sheldon katz set
out revised terms for the foundation's
continued use of facility t
sheldon states that he has reached an
understanding with the counterparty and
that the contents of the document are to
serve as a formal agreement a contract
of sorts between the scp foundation and
someone else according to this contract
the incident with scranton put a strain
on the relationship between the
foundation and whoever the counterparty
is and that the o5 council are seeking
to make amends in order to continue
their new goal of collecting and
containing anomalies so who was this
counterparty that the overseer council
was so desperate to appease and have on
their side who could possibly be a
higher power than the most powerful
secret organization on earth well an
actual higher power of course
that's right the o5 council was making a
deal with god over how they were allowed
to use his blind spot or at least a very
powerful being that considers itself to
be god the rules laid out on their
agreement stated that no person was
permitted to stay at the site of
scp-001 for more than 120 years
including members of the o5 council
along with other members of foundation
staff management researchers security
personnel and test subjects additionally
the scp foundation's ethics committee
was required to annually report any and
all of the 05 council's decisions to god
for his own part god was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath
upon any member of foundation personnel
that's right a perk of working for the
scp foundation is getting
around-the-clock divine protection at
least from god himself that's still a
lot better than an employee dental plan
this came with a condition however that
anyone committing a transgression or
mortal sin was given a 90-day written
notice and an opportunity to repent
their wrong doing in return god demanded
that members of the foundation only
worshipped him and no other divine
entities i the lord am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
was written in the contract finally the
agreement between the o5 council and god
was that they would work together the
foundation and the counterparty would be
equal partners when it came to the
containment of scps and anomalies of all
the strange and unexplained phenomena
that the scp foundation encounters on a
regular basis it hardly comes as much of
a surprise that they've got a direct
line to the big guy upstairs or at least
one who purports to be still the fact
that the o5 council have a business
arrangement with an ultra powerful deity
like being and express written
permission to use this blind spot where
no person can die or age is hardly a
comforting thought at least the scp
foundation only ever uses its power for
good right
oh boy here we go again
scp-001
over 30 different bizarre anomalies
claimed this number one spot in the
database and in a sense they're all
right or are they if you're feeling
confused already that's fine we don't
expect that to change because today
we're dealing with one of the most
strange and intricate zero zero one
entries out there ketter duty just pray
you never get assigned to it you see
when you work around weirdness you
sometimes get a little weird yourself
and nobody deals with more weirdness
than employees of the scp foundation
they regularly rub elbows with
everything from god-like cicadas to
hyper-infectious supernatural viruses
and as the famous tom jones song goes
it's not unusual to suddenly take on
anomalous traits after consistently
working with anomalies for years that's
how the lyrics go right anyway one of
the foundation's most iconic researchers
dr jack bright is technically just an
anomalous necklace himself but outside
of some famous exceptions the scp
foundation is in the business of
containing anomalous entities not hiring
them on and giving them a paycheck and
retirement plan that's why if you
suddenly start displaying anomalous
traits while on the foundation payroll
you might receive a company memo
assigning you to the dreaded ketter duty
but what is cutter duty and what kind of
anomalous traits can get you assigned to
it let's start with the second question
first the official cutter duty
guidelines list a surprisingly vast
number of afflictions these include
chronic anomalous illnesses such as
lycanthropy turning into a werewolf
something called stevenson syndrome and
the incredibly unpleasant sounding
photonic gastric discharge syndrome you
could also be placed on ketter duty
because you're suffering from the
manifestation of spectral phenomena
including being haunted by spirits
whether they're there to torment you or
protect you the sudden expression of
anomalous traits in your dna which is
unsettlingly vague will also land you on
cutter duty as will the awakening of
powerful magical or psionic abilities
especially ones which could be used in a
potentially offensive manner the keter
duty assignment which involves being
relocated and forced to work in a
different highly secretive location that
will be discussed soon is framed as a
punishment for the people involved that
way it discourages foundation employees
from ever trying to develop anomalous
powers on purpose
so what exactly is cater duty and where
does it happen to reinforce that
punishment element method the foundation
has spread lies among their own
personnel about where the job takes
place often involving being posted in
some of the least desirable foundation
areas imaginable these include point
nemo the area of the ocean farthest from
any place of land on earth pyongyang in
north korea stonehenge roswell lunar
area 32 and a number of foundation waste
disposal sites however the reality of
where those on ketter duty end up is
even stranger site 100 which in this
particular instance is the true scp-001
this thaumiel class anomaly is perhaps
the most unique of all multi-anomaly
foundation containment sites a bizarre
labyrinth of non-euclidean geometry that
defies true explanation but we'll do the
best we can in a sense site 100 is a
facility with a mind of its own it's a
sprawling underground base with a layout
that defies space-time and what's more
it undergoes so-called migration events
every so often it will begin to exhibit
a sense of dimensional instability
before teleporting to a different
location somewhere on earth currently
the primary entrance to site 100 known
as alpha entrance is located in the
southwest united states though all signs
point to another migration event
happening this very year but knowing
where the entrance is will only get you
so far people assigned to cutter duty
are sent from the alpha entrance to the
administration sector to be given their
initial breaching at which point the
true madness begins let's take a look at
a map of site 100 yikes so there are 10
major sectors in site 100 that you
should be aware of entrance alpha
administration archives technological
containment biocontainment sapient
containment cognitohazardous mimetic and
semantic or cms containment esoteric
containment conceptual containment and
the core sector as you can tell they
have almost everything covered here but
just as insane as the anomalies that
site 100 contains and the methods they
use to contain them is how you actually
get around the site site 100 is a
spatial anomaly of truly epic
proportions while the foundation is
aware of the existence of its competent
sectors it's impossible to map out any
meaningful connections between them it
would be pretty much impossible to even
travel from one to another without
passageways known as the roots however
these aren't just mere portals that you
can hop through like the ways in and out
of the wanderers library each route
between the sectors is its own complex
environment with its own sets of
protocols and rituals required to safely
travel through it root aleph the bridge
between the archives and the
inaccessible core of site 100 is a
volcanic beach blocked off by an
apparently limitless obsidian wall where
fish made from living rock swim in the
nearby waters root bath connecting the
core and sapient containment is a huge
and sprawling funhouse hall of mirrors
anyone who attempts to travel through it
inevitably ends up turned around and
arrives back at their starting point in
sapient containment route dallas the
bridge that connects conceptual
containment and the core is a massive
ocean that has resisted all attempts by
the foundation to traverse it root valve
the bridge between esoteric containment
and conceptual containment is a massive
field filled with unidentified fruit
trees foundation expeditions have found
that it too seems impossible to traverse
one expedition team was trapped inside
for a whole year until one member of the
team expressed a desire to go home at
that point they were immediately
teleported back to the starting point
rude sade connecting administration to
the cms sector is a huge lush forest on
top of a floating mountain the only
animals that seem to populate this
forest are non-anomalous flamingos next
we have root pet the bridge between the
archive and the administration which
appears to be a hallway on the fifth
floor of a tenement building in a city
that the foundation haven't been able to
locate this building is populated by
non-hostile humanoid creatures we'll
approach foundation staff traversing
route pay and invite them into their
apartments offering to partake in
recreational activities with them such
as video games board games or watching
movies the foundation discourages its
staff from accepting any of these offers
while on the job and then there's root
shin which connects the sapient and
conceptual containment sectors this
route is unique in the sense that it
acts as a power generator for the rest
of site 100 as it's filled with hundreds
of large perpetual motion machines
producing a constant 8.7 gigawatts of
electricity these are only some of the
many routes illustrated on the site 100
diagram as you've probably gathered by
now it's less like a conventional
building and more like a whole crazy
dimension unto itself why does the
foundation work to maintain such a crazy
place wouldn't it just be easier to keep
it a secret and contain it like any
other anomaly well site 100 wouldn't be
given the scp-001 designation if it
wasn't incredibly important if site 100
was ever compromised it would lead to an
inevitable k-class end-of-the-world
scenario because the site is
intrinsically tied to the nature and
containment of literally every single
ketter class scp in our universe hence
the nickname ketertuti for those working
at the site in fact an anomaly can't
even be classed as a ketter if it isn't
given permission by site 100 the various
sectors of site 100 cover the entire
spectrum of anomalies and each sector is
a massive panoptix structure connected
by networks of glass elevators whenever
a new ketter class scp is discovered its
name and a brief description of its
anomalous traits will inscribe itself on
one of the walls in its corresponding
sector ever been frustrated when the o5
council refused to sign off on an
upgrade to cut her class for a clearly
dangerous scp that poses extreme risk of
containment breach don't blame them it's
simply that site 100 didn't sanction the
change anytime that site 100 sanctions a
new scp it also undergoes another unique
process it selects an
scp-001-k instance for the new ketter
and creates a connection between them
using access points known as thresholds
think of it as simply opening a
spatially anomalous door between two as
cps much like a good boy another scp
vying for the zero zero one slot site
100 has an intuitive grasp of the unseen
connections between ketter class
anomalies and each
scp-001-k instance is a complementary
ketter class that will essentially
cancel out the threat of its other half
site 100 is a containment matchmaker its
innate ability to use the anomalous to
contain the anomalous is second to none
first it took
scp-3984 an anomalous phenomenon that
seemed to prevent death from happening
to all life forms in order to mitigate
the effects of 3984 site 100 opened a
threshold between it and scp-2935
also known as oh death an alternate
universe hidden beyond a limestone
cavern where all life simultaneously
ceased to exist even down to the
bacterial level by opening the threshold
and allowing these two absolute
opposites to mix it seemed to undermine
the effects of both and create a
non-anomalous happy medium life but
mortal life next scp-5007
this terrifying underwater anomaly
manifests as a series of tentacle-like
protrusions that snatch unfortunate
creatures that get too close and
assimilate them into its own mass site
100 cleverly opened a threshold to
scp-169
a massive underwater anthropod known as
the leviathan
scp-169 was tangled up by the tentacles
but it's too big to be fully consumed or
assimilated and the result is that 5007
is trapped in a perpetually
incapacitated state akin to choking
keeping it contained and stopping it
from going after anyone else let's take
a look at two even more hostile and
dangerous cheddar class anomalies
matched up by site 100 first we've got
scp-5501 an old camera from the 1800s
that comes with 18 photographs these
photographs act as a kind of portal to
an incredibly frightening alternate
reality that creatures regularly crawl
out of attacking and killing anyone
within reach site 100 found a perfect
match for this nasty customer
scp-1983 this is a small house that acts
as a portal to a race of tall monsters
with needle-like appendages that leave
the house in search of victims when they
catch these victims they take out their
hearts and bring them back to the nest
site 100 opened a threshold into the
scp-1983 house and placed the 5501
photographs inside as a result the
hostile creatures from both dimensions
now regulate each other's populations by
killing each other another job well done
for site 100 another ketter class dealt
with by scp-100 is scp-pl122
this is a deadly plot of land in poland
which decays and corrodes all matter
organic or inorganic placed within its
confines this would be bad enough but as
you'll often find with anomalous plots
of deadly land its area of influence is
growing even knowing about it can cause
it to become more powerful but site 100
found its perfect ketter class
counterpart
scp-1262 this is a massive mass of plant
matter that grows at a truly astonishing
rate expanding by around 7 kilometers an
hour much like absolute death and
absolute life by putting 1262 into
scp-pl122
a healthy medium was found somewhere in
between and finally perhaps the
strangest and most creative match site
100 has ever pulled off
scp-3852 and scp-2547
3852 is an anonymous corpse that
manifests in small towns sowing fear and
suspicion eventually a local person is
believed to be responsible for this
murder and is lynched in a rage by the
townspeople as a form of vigilante
justice the corpse then moves on to the
next town 2547 if you can believe it is
even weirder it's a pack of dogs led by
an intelligent talking coyote dressed as
a priest site 100 had the truly galaxy
brain idea to open a threshold and
connect the two as a result whenever the
corpse manifests in the town the dogs
rampage in and take over at that point
they set up a kind of ridiculous
kangaroo court where a jury made up of
people from the town are forced to find
3852's scapegoat innocent if they don't
the dogs will simply hold the town's
water supply hostage until 3852's
anomalous effects pass such an obvious
idea now why didn't the foundation think
of that ketter duty may not be the most
conventional easy or attractive work but
like everything the foundation does
making sure site 100 can keep doing its
job is a necessary part of keeping our
world safe from anomalous threats now if
you'll excuse us we need to get going
do you know which is the right route out
of here say kids would you like to hear
a story cause we've got a really good
one for you
seriously you're going to love it it's a
classic rags to riches tale about one
man's rise from humble beginnings to
become one of history's greatest and
most visionary toy makers or
maybe it isn't maybe it's about a
company that literally came from nothing
whose origins are still shrouded in
mystery maybe it's about a woman
breaking the glass ceiling to take over
the toy company left to her by her
eccentric father maybe it's about all of
these things but the one thing we can
tell you about the story of dr
wondertainment is that every word of it
is true or at least as far as anything
is true in the weird wonderful world of
the scp foundation as long as you
believe we'll all have a wonderful time
as long as you believe
nothing can hurt you
not in the fabulous world of doctor
wondertainment dr wondertainment is the
name given to scp-001
who due to his relatively benign nature
has been classified as safe by the
foundation rather than focusing on
containing wondertainment himself the
scp foundation has centered its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a class one reality warper
capable of constructing otherwise normal
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially
dangerous toys and games that are
distributed by as yet unknown memes many
of wundertainment's toys are in the
foundation's possession such as
scp-445 origami paper that takes on
properties of whatever it's folded to
look like and
scp-3147 lollipops that allow people to
switch voices with each other dr
wondertainment was born into a family of
humble means his mother was a seamstress
and his father was an accountant
unsatisfied with his mundane life
wondertainment's only joy growing up was
in the stories that his father would
tell him about an ancestor of his who
was once a famous toy maker inspired by
these stories wondertainment developed
an interest in crafting toys and as an
adult set out to learn the secrets he
would need to create toys unlike
anything the world had ever seen he
spent his life following rumors of
magical artifacts and enchanted trinkets
until his search brought him to a
mysterious factory if you've seen our
previous videos on scp-001 proposals you
can probably guess that this factory was
the factory the mysterious place where
new scps are supposedly created
wondertainment barely escaped the
massacre and the foundation takeover of
the factory with his life but he was
able to find a variety of notes that he
took with him these notes contained
clues that led him to the workshop of
his famous toymaker ancestor and from
there he reclaimed his birthright that
was the day that he truly became dr
it's a fun story isn't it very
straightforward but perhaps it is a
little underwhelming for an scp-001
proposal after all
scp-001 is the collective designation
given to some of the most important
anomalies of all time including many
that could have potentially been
involved in the foundation's very
founding hmm let's start again reginald
filbert lionel archibald westinghouse
wondertainment iii is the name given to
scp-001
who due to his highly unpredictable
nature has been classed as euclid by the
foundation and he is to be detained as
soon as his location can be
ascertained until he can be captured the
scp foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a class two reality warper
capable of constructing otherwise normal
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and
potentially dangerous toys games candy
soft drinks and other products aimed at
children and young teens these products
are distributed by as yet unknown means
many of wondertainment's creations are
in foundation possession such as the
often imitated but never matched little
misters collection which are a group of
living collectibles with unique
anomalous properties due to
entertainment's reality warping
abilities it is impossible to pin down
concrete information about his history
what we can tell you for sure is that
he's immortal and ageless and comes from
a long line of wondertainment stretching
all the way back to the cretaceous
period where they made all sorts of toys
for the good little dinosaur children
it's also widely known that he is in
fact not a real person but merely the
manifestation of the dreams of every
child on earth brought forth solely by
the power of imagination no confirmed
sightings of dr wondertainment have ever
occurred but witnesses have described
him as dashing very handsome for his age
and a lovely chap capable of creating
whimsy and wonder with the snap of his
fingers he's a tall man about the height
of a piece of string and he's
immediately recognizable by his walking
stick and w-shaped mustache it's also
been reported that he has scarring
around the circumference of both wrists
almost as if his hands have been removed
and reattached at some point however the
truth of the matter is that
hmm no no we're telling it all wrong
again this doesn't do anything to
capture the scope of the wondertainment
story it needs to feel
bigger more
comprehensive let's try it again
dr wondertainment is a trademark of the
wondertainment toy company the name
given to scp-001
a corporation that due to its consistent
output of anomalous items is classed by
the foundation as ketter until this
company can be permanently shut down the
scp foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that it
creates the collective power of the
company's constituent employees and the
technology they make use are equivalent
to that of a class 3 reality warper the
wondertainment company produces and
sells a range of products ranging from
the seemingly normal to the downright
weird all imbued with anomalous
properties the company has become
infamous for their constant output of
bizarre magical and potentially
dangerous toys games candy soft drinks
and other products aimed at children
teens and young at heart adults these
products are made and distributed from
wonder world trademark a location that
is yet unknown to the foundation but
offers factory tours every hour from
tuesday to friday
many of wondertainment's creations are
in foundation possession such as
wondertainment's famous dragon snails
the real fire-breathing pet you can keep
in your pocket not much is known about
the inner workings of the wondertainment
company the scp foundation has no
information currently on the company's
leadership structure location history or
corporate policies various former and
current employees have been interviewed
regarding their experiences working for
wondertainment but they never seem to be
able to remember very much of use those
interviewed variously described the
wondertainment company as a regular
office building an immense toy factory
an amusement park but all agree it's the
best place they ever worked in fact you
should apply for a job there we i i mean
they have a few openings in their legal
department or so i've heard oh silly me
it seems we've gotten off topic you're
here to hear about the scp-001 proposal
posting a job ad wasn't what i meant to
do when i hacked into
[Laughter]
i mean well don't worry about that
forget i said a thing now let's try this
again but this time we'll add a twist
isabel helga anastasia parvati
wondertainment v is the name given to
scp-001
who due to her ability to spread
sunshine and whimsy wherever she goes
has been classed as thomiel by the
foundation and due to her immensely
unpredictable nature the scp foundation
has resolved to just leave her be
because she can't be captured the scp
foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that she creates
she is a class 4 reality warper capable
of constructing wonderful funtastic
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties she's famous and widely
beloved for using this ability to create
bizarre magical and not even a little
bit dangerous toys games candy soft
drinks and other products aimed at
everyone from ages 9 to 99. these
products are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of wundertainment's
creations are in foundation possession
such as
scp-3551 the awesome inflatable alien
invaders and scp-2514
a lovely horse who can sing happy
birthday
how grabbed wondertainment inherited the
wondertainment name from her father who
either passed away or never existed at
all the circumstances of his death and
perhaps non-existence were very
messy involving a mass murderer the
leader of a shadowy international extra
governmental paramilitary organization
at least one deity and four bent
paperclips she owns six corgis and all
of them are named jeremy in a free time
she likes to
no
no this is all still wrong all right
enough is enough you want to know who dr
wondertainment really is well you asked
for it dr wondertainment is the name
given to scp-001
who due to his deity level power has
been classed as apollyon by the
foundation there is no possible way to
contain him he is a class five reality
warper capable of breaking down and
reconstructing the very laws of reality
did you really think that those little
trinkets were the full extent of my i
mean
his creations did you truly think of him
as such a small petty creature dr
wondertainment is no mere toy smith no
he
is a god want examples of his creations
just look around you everything from the
most innocent safe class to the most
harrowing ketter class it's all thanks
to him he is behind everything marshall
carter and dark the sarcists the church
of the broken god even the scarlet king
himself all that time all that effort
all it came down to was one entity one
singular living personification of chaos
one day the scp foundation will finally
give up trying to find out how he
distributes his products when they will
finally see how small and worthless
their attempts to restore order really
are and they will be driven before his
power they will crumble and decay into
nothingness you will bow before doctor
wondertainment
[Laughter]
had you going for a second there didn't
we you should have seen the looks on
your faces but let's start again
one more time we're being serious this
time mask off here's the true story of
dr wondertainment dr wondertainment is
the name given to scp-001
due to his relatively benign nature has
been classed as neutralized by the
foundation rather than focusing on
containing wondertainment himself the
scp foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a reality warper whose
limits have yet to be documented capable
of constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
and games that are distributed by as yet
unknown means due to his secretive
nature almost nothing is known of dr
wondertainment's true origins and the
waters have been muddied extensively by
the side effects of his reality warping
ability in fact it's entirely possible
that dr wondertainment himself doesn't
know who he is anymore it's possible
that all the proposed origins and
descriptions of dr wondertainment are
true in their own way but it is equally
possible that none of them are all
that's known for sure is that dr
wondertainment be they male or female
corporation or single individual is a
constant thorn in the scp foundation's
side no matter who they really are
they're not going away soon and only
time will tell who they'll be tomorrow
or what further horrors they and their
company will create and that's where our
story will have to come to an end at
least for now we hope you enjoyed it and
remember keep believing
let's get one thing clear as much as it
is fun to go through the various
articles on the scp archive we should
take a moment to acknowledge that it's
all fun and games the scp foundation all
the entities and objects creatures and
people places and stories related to
them are just that stories fiction
created by the authors of an online wiki
website it's all designed to be a bit of
harmless entertainment but what if it
isn't harmless what if the characters
within the world of the scp archives
somehow knew they had been created by
the scp wiki authors what would happen
if fiction was aware that it was in fact
fictional ask yourself would you want to
know if your world your life everything
you had ever seen or known was just all
fantasy if the answer is no then you
need to stop watching this video right
now but we'll warn you just because you
don't know about something doesn't
necessarily stop it from being true
still want to find out what's going on
good then you need to hear about scp-001
first things first which of the various
scp-001s are we talking about anyone
looking for the earliest scp will
quickly discover that there are many
different entities and anomalies that
share that number there are a few
in-universe reasons for this one is that
all these anomalies were discovered in
the earliest days of the scp foundation
before their current numbering system
was introduced then there's the other
theories for example some have
speculated that the existence of many
different
scp-001s is an intentional misdirection
by the foundation
their way of keeping the nature of the
first true scp a closely guarded secret
regardless of what the reason is the
scp-001 we're looking at today is also
known as the database any and all
information about the database is kept
secret from the entire scp foundation
apart from the overseer council and why
is it such a secret well that's because
scp-001 contains details of the very
nature of the foundation itself
including its creation but we don't mean
when and how the organization was
founded or its history we mean how it
was created and by whom in our reality
confused well allow us to explain it at
first the file for scp-001 describes a
group of humanoid entities that have the
ability to influence reality all sounds
like pretty standard bread and butter
stuff for the scp foundation right wrong
these entities are in fact the authors
of the scp wiki themselves as in the
people in the real world the reality of
the scp foundation is constantly changed
by these writers written and rewritten
whenever someone edits an article on the
scp wiki that's all fine and harmless
for us but the wiki author's impact on
their world is cause of grave concern
for the foundation as we mentioned at
the start we all know that the scp
foundation and its vast catalog of
user-generated articles on the creative
and the creepy are nothing more than a
source of fictional online entertainment
it can be fun to study the lore and the
nuances of the different scps it can be
enjoyable appreciating the creativity
and hard work that the authors put into
writing them in the case of fan fiction
independent stories original scps or
even animated videos dedicated to
explaining them it can even inspire and
fuel our own written endeavors but at
the end of the day when all is said and
done we all know that the scp foundation
is purely fictional what we don't
realize is that the foundation knows it
too containing several pieces of
information from within their own
archive the database contains everything
the foundation knows about our real
world this includes everything about the
real authors of the scp wiki and you
thought deadpool was meta you see
because the scp wiki has articles from
numerous different creative writers
chances are the details of every new
article might not always line up with
every previous one for a long time there
has been much discussion amongst devoted
scp fans regarding the canon of the
website now we don't mean a big gun that
launches metal balls when we say canon
we mean all of the events and stories
that are considered to be an official
part of the ongoing story of the scp
foundation still with us so far because
there are so many writers and articles
on the wiki the canon of the scp archive
is a bit inconsistent to say the least
and that's fine for us because we know
none of it is real it doesn't have to
all line up just as long as a good story
is being told but these inconsistencies
all the little cracks of discrepancy and
disparity are what made the foundation
themselves realize that they are truly
living in a fiction in other words
scp-001
is the scp foundation's window through
what we would experience as the fourth
wall the fourth wall is the metaphorical
barrier that separates what we know to
be real from what we know to be purely
fiction in other words it's the line
between the audience and the fiction
that they are watching the edge of the
stage or the glass of the television
screen and the scp foundation is staring
through that fourth wall looking out at
you and me
that's right it isn't just the authors
that the foundation are aware of it's
all of us according to their own
researchers the foundation has
determined that we the audience and the
writers exist in something known as the
alpha layer what on earth is an alpha
layer well imagine our reality the world
and the universe as we know it is a
slice of bread it's a strange analogy we
know but stick with us now picture the
fictional world of the scp foundation as
another slice of bread underneath ours
in between the two can be whatever you
like but the point isn't that the world
is a sandwich the point is that we exist
on a layer of reality above that of the
scp wiki and the filling is just what
keeps reality and fiction separate so as
we mentioned the foundation is aware of
any writers and readers of the scp wiki
and this does include you but the wiki
authors are the primary focus of the
database after all it's the writers who
are responsible for creating the
fictional world that the scp foundation
exists in anything that forms a part of
the narrative of that world every
article every tale every new scp that
gets published even parts of the wiki
that get taken down or rewritten all
have an impact on the foundation's
universe when the authors link their new
scps to pre-existing ones or create
connections to a group of interests like
the church of the broken god or the
global occult coalition their writing
ends up making even more of a
substantial development to the overall
narrative and all of it ends up in the
database the readers of the scp wiki on
the other hand are a smaller part of
scp-001 mainly because they do not write
or publish the content found on the
website itself anything that is not
specifically set in stone by a wiki
author can be interpreted in various
ways by a reader a reader's
interpretation is a powerful concept and
should not be underestimated
interpretation is the difference between
reading animal farm as a story about a
group of animals rebelling against their
human farmer and understanding it as a
satirical and political allegory for the
events leading up to the russian
revolution so what does interpretation
have to do with scp-001
the point we are getting at is that any
unwritten detail or anything that isn't
explicitly stated by a wiki author can
be changed by a reader's own imagination
this can be anything from the appearance
or personality of an scp or character to
a detail about the world of the
foundation and in the same vein if
something in one scp article contradicts
something written in another the reader
is free to choose which of them they
accept as part of the universe's true
canon each reader of the scp wiki has
their own understanding of the material
written there and inevitably comprehends
their own version of the events within
and this is something that the scp
foundation even in their world of
fiction is aware of or more specifically
the o5 council is aware of you see the
secretive overseers are the only ones
with any true knowledge of scp-001
only they can access the database only
they know the truth the fact that they
exist in this fictional capacity is
something the overseer council hopes to
hide from the rest of the foundation's
personnel in an effort to keep the rest
of their staff from asking too many
questions the council has told them that
there is currently no way in existence
that they could possibly contain
scp-001
but to reassure personnel the o5s have
also stated that this does not pose any
risk nor would it lead to the total and
utter destruction of their observable
fictional universe instead the council
aims to focus on what they can control
by containing any and all information
about scp-001
nothing about the database or the truth
that it contains is to ever leave o5
command under any circumstances
whatsoever all the information about
scp-001 or what it contains
is kept in an encrypted highly
classified form at an unknown location
the key needed to decrypt this data is a
passcode split into three parts this key
is then memorized by members of the o5
council each memorizing a different
portion of the passcode it can only be
accessed if every member of the council
unanimously agrees that it is absolutely
necessary and even when they do decrypt
the information about
scp-001 it remains for the eyes of o5
command and strictly their eyes only any
member of the scp foundation caught
leaking data about
scp-001 is to be contained by any means
necessary this also includes if a member
of personnel attempts to get this
classified information out via espionage
psychic leakage or other devious methods
foundation researchers are even banned
from conducting any of their own
investigations into the nature of
scp-001 or the data it contains if a
lower-level staff member was somehow to
find out the truth that the entire
foundation is just a fiction then that
person would be at the mercy of the most
senior figure on the o5 council it would
be up to that senior figure to decide
the staff member's fate anyone with high
enough clearance or status within the
foundation who found out about scp-001
would alternatively be given a class a
amnestic these are memory altering drugs
that the scp foundation uses to keep
information about anomalies a secret
apparently even from its own staff still
having your mind wiped has got to be
better than being killed or contained
just for realizing you're a fictional
character on an online wiki the o5
console has plans in mind for us and for
the scp wiki writers responsible for
creating them the scp wiki entry on the
database closes with a proposal a way
that the o5 council can reach out of
their fiction directly to the wiki's
authors in the real world from there
their goal is simple through memetic
kill agents the scp foundation will put
the wiki authors to sleep and then kill
them sounds pretty far-fetched doesn't
it after all when was the last time
something fictional killed someone in
our real world even more bizarre what if
this kill agent really exists the o5
council must have known for a while that
their world is fictional so they've had
plenty of time to develop a kill agent
some way of reaching us and the scp wiki
authors in the real world worse still
what if this kill agent is already out
there somewhere lurking on the scp
archive just waiting for you to find it
and if you read it how would it kill you
if you don't want to know then that's
your choice to make but if curiosity is
getting the better of you then remember
this beware scp-5999
[Music]
if you ask anyone any person from any
culture any part of the world to
describe what death looks like most
people will immediately jump to a
depiction of the grim reaper and rightly
so the reaper has long been the
personification of death and decay an
omen of demise the cloak skeleton
bearing a sharp scythe coming to collect
souls and carrying them off to either
heaven or hell for centuries human
beings have thought of the grim reaper
as death itself but he's more of an
embodiment of it a symbol meant to
represent that all too familiar fear of
not knowing what lies beyond life on
this fragile mortal plane of existence
death itself the real death looks
completely different welcome to the
story of scp-001
now first things first to anyone
familiar with the scp foundation you
will most likely know that there are
multiple scp-001s
you might even think that you know which
of them is the real one but for those of
you who are new here allow us to clarify
for you this important context the
designation of scp-001
does not refer to a single creature
object or entity but rather a collection
of various anomalies that are allegedly
kept contained by the scp foundation now
there are multiple explanations as to
why these various files are all
collected under the shared designation
of scp-001
one explanation could be that this is
because these anomalies are some of the
earliest ever contained by the
foundation by this rationale all the
scp-001
share the same designation because they
were first encountered before the scp
foundation established the numbering
system that it currently uses however
there also exists a theory that this is
nothing more than intentional
misdirection if we choose to believe
this explanation then it could mean that
the many different
scp-001s are a devious ploy by the
foundation themselves in the interest of
maintaining secrecy and security having
many files sharing the name scp-001
could be the foundation's way of keeping
the nature of the true first scp a
closely guarded secret it seems
plausible that the multiple scp-001
files could be an attempt by the
foundation to conceal information after
all it wouldn't be the first time this
secretive organization deceived someone
so what exactly is this particularly
morbid take on scp-001
well first you have to have a pretty
high level of security clearance within
the scp foundation if you want to even
come close to accessing this file in
fact any and all details about the
anomaly codename dead men is protected
by helen stick an aic used by the
foundation's overwatch command also
known as the o5 council an aic for those
who are not yet aware is an advanced
form of artificial intelligence that the
foundation develops and uses to run
parts of its archive of anomalies what
does that mean for scp-001 well it's
pretty simple the people in charge of
the foundation want this file to remain
secure or it could be because the o5
council is hiding something something
that the general staff members aren't
meant to know about getting past all the
additional security surrounding this
particular file we learned that
scp-001 or this one at least is an old
man an 84 year old man to be precise
wait that's it that's what the big
closely guarded secret is just some old
guy no of course he's not just some old
guy the foundation's highest ranking
members wouldn't go through such trouble
over one ordinary man this particular
man has become one with death not the
reaper no
death itself the very concept of death
has been merged with this individual a
lot more interesting than just a normal
old man right to be clear this man is
not an incarnation or embodiment of
death like the grim reaper instead he
has become a vessel for the process of
making something that was once alive
not so this old man
scp-001 can control life and death not
quite the old man's body is more like a
way that death itself can be influenced
it may help to picture it like this
imagine scp-001 as a television remote
control for death except instead of
pressing buttons like you would on a
remote you have to remove or alter parts
of the old man's body and in doing so
you can manipulate the process of death
albeit only to a limited extent you
can't for example permanently stop death
from existing or occurring stopping
everyone around the world from dying
that's not quite how
scp-001 works here let's give you an
example
scp-001 had his tongue removed as well
as had sustained damage to his eardrums
before he was contained by the
foundation so as a result of those
alterations to his body there are fewer
deals with death events in the modern
era you see what we mean now changing
scp-001 changes how death functions but
doesn't necessarily stop it from
happening so in essence although there
are parameters
scp-001 is the foundation's way of
controlling death itself how did they
decide to go about doing this well once
we tell you you will understand why the
o5 council wanted to keep information
about scp-001
such as secret after performing a series
of complex brain surgeries and various
other procedures on the old man the
overwatch command intentionally
engineered him to be unable to perceive
certain people who were those people you
guessed it the o5 council themselves
making scp-001 unable to recognize the
faces of any o5 council members means
that death is unable to see or perceive
the council members either all those
pieces fit together to form a
particularly unsettling jigsaw puzzle by
tampering with scp-001 the o5 council
have made themselves effectively
immortal they cannot die nor will they
age or decay like normal mortal human
beings death still occurs of course
other beings can die but the council
members are exempt from that fundamental
law of nature the foundation believes
that scp-001 was initially created by an
occult group known as the eternal circle
thanks to records recovered from the
circle's london headquarters the scp
foundation now knows that they were the
ones responsible for merging the old man
with the concept of death when their
personnel first recovered scp-001
the old man was frail in a poor physical
condition and barely responded to any
external stimuli research staff believe
he must have suffered severe trauma at
the hands of the eternal circle
evidenced by the circular symbols that
had been carved into his back oh and
also the fact that his body parts had
all been modified contained within the
file for this scp-001
is a letter directly from the o5 council
themselves explaining their reasons for
using the old man to become immortal
they justify their actions by claiming
that they have a wealth of experience in
containing anomalies and keeping the scp
foundation running this is to them a
perfectly valid reason to make
themselves exempt from death rather than
aging retiring and dying to later be
replaced by new members on the overwatch
council they claim that their
immortality is not for their own
self-benefit of course but for the good
of the foundation as an organization and
by extension the world as a whole the
council also promised that the same
death exempt status would later be
extended to other vital members of
personnel however according to the
hellenistic aic guarding the file no
personnel have been considered for death
exempt status in the future in other
words the o5 council were lying and
intended to keep their get out of death
free card to themselves it wasn't long
before the foundation's very own ethics
committee learned about what the council
was up to and naturally they had some
concerns according to a report issued by
committee chairman odongo tajani the way
the o5 council were using scp-001 to
prolong their own lives was immoral and
inhumane even by their own strange
standards by using this poor frail old
man for their own gain the council had
warped the natural way death should work
and threatened to anomalously unbalance
the very laws of nature the ethics
committee had no other choice but to
dispatch its own mobile task force known
as omega 1 or the law's left hand to
rectify the situation their mission to
detain all members of the o5 council at
their next meeting removing them from
office and replacing them with
high-ranking candidates from within the
foundation's lower ranks finally they
also plan to neutralize scp-001
cleaning house and removing the
temptation for future council members to
make themselves immortal in short this
was a coup the o5 council was going to
be overthrown by their own ethics
committee of course the council was more
than prepared for this and also had
their very own mobile task force on hand
to defend them against the plot alpha 1
also known under the code name red right
hand the legendary lackeys of the o5
council clash with the law's left hand
it is believed that the shadowy
administrator of the scp foundation also
had his own personal task force possibly
reish one also called the seat of
consciousness enter the fray in other
words we were looking at an absolutely
insane three-way foundation civil war
bloodbath how exciting security footage
showed these three groups engaged in a
firefight within site-01 using
foundation training and tactics against
each other in what would probably be the
most epic battle of all of their lives
it was absolute chaos the air thick with
screams and gun gunsmoke cameras also
picked up a group of men and women lying
all around site-01 many wounded but
still alive impressive given how many of
them had taken gunshots right to their
heads that's right these were presumed
to be the members of the o5 council
still unable to die despite being shot
it is unclear which of the mtfs were
responsible for this the ethics
committee had only intended law's left
hand to secure the council members it
could well be that they were caught in
the crossfire that occurred as the law's
left hand and red right-hand teams
fought unless of course the
administrators task force were the ones
who had stepped in and shot the o5
council through all the chaos that had
unfurled scp-001
was still in this cell and he wasn't
alone an unknown figure had somehow
gained access and he conversed with
scp-001
the man went on to tell scp-001 that the
foundation was wrong to tamper with the
nature of death and recounted a story he
said that he had once filed paperwork
regarding anomalies for an unknown
organization but couldn't live with the
horror of what his job entailed so the
man sold these files to a group of 13
individuals the o5 council they then
went on to form a full organization the
scp foundation as we know it the man
then stated that he was disgusted with
how the foundation had used as cp-001
how the council members had engineered
the frail old man to make themselves
immortal he had hoped that they would be
a force for good keeping any necessary
evil to a minimum the unknown figure
told scp-001 that the conflict between
the council and the ethics committee had
happened many times before with many
other versions of the old man earlier
scp-001s previously merged with the
concept of death he then helped scp-001
identify the members of the council
ending their immortality promising the
weak tired old man that he'd finally be
able to rest the unknown mystery man
claimed that he would always be in power
the 0-5 council would always bring him
back after all he was their figurehead
their leader the scp foundation
administrator himself in the end the
administrator himself chose to let
himself perish too perhaps in shame of
what his organization had become or did
he because someone seems to have been
accessing the helen stick aic and the
scp-001 file using his login since this
incident maybe the hand of death doesn't
reach quite as far as we were led to
believe and that's where the tale of
scp-001
ends a story of the foundation's greed
and their pursuit of eternal life we
mustn't forget that death isn't
something to be afraid of after all it
gives our lives meaning knowing that
they will one day end but when you look
at the kind of monsters we can become in
the pursuit of eternal life well in the
words of another wise old man sometimes
dead is better
does the black moon howl
no
not yet
see the boy
he was born in a time before names there
weren't enough humans around to need
them back then he was one of a handful
occupying a coastal village using a
tongue long since dead they eked out a
simple life hunting gathering
fishing the only thing on most of their
minds was surviving to see the next
sunrise yes a simple life free of
complications until the hermit appeared
the boy would remember this man for
eternity haggard and thin skin weathered
by time and pain a man that emaciated
walking with a long gnarled cane that
honestly looked healthier than he did
shouldn't be alive even the boy who had
scarcely seen beyond the bounds of his
village knew that the hermit was
unnatural an aberration an anomaly
he walked into the center of the village
sat down on a large stone and waited
nobody dared ask his business nor what
the hermit waited for then a few days
later the black moon howled the boys saw
the village's youngest hunter freeze one
evening while out on a walk not simply
stand still but freeze then for an
instant he became solid black a coal
statue and as soon as he'd changed he
was gone
obliterated not a trace of him remained
such is the power of the black moon it
can make any conscious being disappear
in an instant turned black then wiped
from our plane of existence never to be
seen again its choice of victims seemed
at each instance to be utterly random
but it would come for all who lived
eventually this is known to some as the
howling of the black moon later that
same night the boy found himself talking
to the hermit who asked with small
frantic eyes what he had seen when the
boy told him he let out a deep rattling
sigh
the boy curious asked him if he knew
about the nightmare he'd just witnessed
the hermit looked up he'd been the first
one in the hermit's millennia of pursuit
that had ever asked in that moment he
knew that he had found his successor in
the hunt for the death of ages the
hermit told the boy it went by many
names
the great finale the pale king but most
common of all was the black moon the
entity existed beyond the veil of our
reality a creature of pure energy though
nobody could really be sure of its true
nature the hermit had been tracking it
learning about it and trying to destroy
it for thousands of years and yet it
only took him four pathetic minutes to
tell the boy everything he knew the boy
knowing still that something about the
hermit was unnatural asked how he came
to be in this position the hermit told
the boy he was the counterbalance a kind
of chosen one destined to face and
perhaps even defeat the black moon
someday the counterbalance receives a
number of truly extraordinary gifts for
inheriting the responsibility eternal
life eternal youth near physical
immortality but they will be haunted by
their purpose
doomed to watch everyone they love die
around them as they continue to hunt
their only true equal and opposite the
black moon itself the hermit in his own
eyes had failed at his duty he had grown
weary and now he needed to pass the duty
of counterbalance onto another that
other would be the boy he felt a sudden
and profound change along with the
knowledge that nothing would ever be the
same again he was no longer just the boy
now
he was the counterbalance he watched the
hermit give him a slight nod of respect
and then crumble into dust before his
eyes the boy
the counterbalance looked up at the sky
and saw the stars twinkling so bright
and so beautiful little did he know his
battle with the black moon would outlast
every single one of them does the black
moon howl
not without blood the boy grew into a
man as his village aged and then died
around him decades past then centuries
then millennia tens of thousands of
years watching humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving beyond all
the old superstitions the counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the
black moon though even then it still
remained essentially a stranger the
entity was entropic a being of pure
randomness and chaos without consistent
form it didn't exist in our universe but
it could exercise its influence here
with so-called obliteration events much
like the horrible fate that befell the
young hunter from the village but that
was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg the counterbalance tracked and
noted obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second he'd spell the end of all
conscious life a total victory for the
black moon the end of the universe the
death of ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless the counterbalance had
discovered many other things along the
way
strange creatures objects with
extraordinary powers and events that
couldn't be explained with rational
science perhaps something about these
oddities these anomalies would hold the
key to defeating his timeless enemy and
it hadn't just been these objects
entities and events he'd also discovered
some truly exceptional people on his
travels minds and skills that rivaled
even his own despite his age perhaps
they would be the ones to help him win
with the 13 most brilliant and trusted
people the counterbalance ever met he
decided to form a council and from this
council they forged and directed an
organization dedicated to understanding
and counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
search into darkness would yield the
answer to the black moon's downfall he
called it the scp foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title the fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power scps
does the black moon howl only at the
blind the year was now 1987. the scp
foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity while there still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability to
gather intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new global
information network their top minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known as the singular conceptual
bunker which may one day come in handy
for combating the extra dimensional
entity directly but the most valuable
piece of information they ever gathered
about the black moon was this it
couldn't howl when it was being watched
the very act of engaged observation
defanged it the problem is how can you
observe something that doesn't
technically exist inside your own
reality in order to pull this off the
foundation would need to get extremely
creative thankfully creative solutions
to strange problems are the foundation
specialty flash forward to 1993 enter dr
moto a brilliant young scientist and
conceptual engineer working for the scp
foundation with the administrator's
consultation he started the key project
an arm of the wider project auromacides
the umbrella initiative for using
modified anomalous objects in the battle
against the black moon the goal of the
key project was relatively simple if
people couldn't observe the black moon
directly then the foundation could make
proxies of the black moon that could be
observed
almost like a kind of voodoo doll these
new anomalies would only need to satisfy
three criteria the inability to operate
when being observed a hostility to
conscious life and the ability to end
conscious life of their own volition
when not being observed through
conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory dr moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted escape by barging
through site-01 the center for
anti-black moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 0.2 seconds
almost all of moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientists felt a deep
shame but forged on he made one truly
brilliant creation that satisfied all
the criteria a sculpture incapable of
moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project dr moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously
all the deaths in the key project had
been for nothing the black moon was only
getting more powerful the shame and the
guilt was too much for dr moto he left a
note in his office reading we've been
looking at nothing i'm sorry
administrator i failed you sir moto's
corpse was later found in the
sculpture's temporary containment
chamber his neck snapped the key project
was in summary shut down and it's one
surviving creation transported to site
19 in late 1993 where it was designated
as
scp-173 another painful failure for the
administrator
back to the drawing board once more does
the black moon howl not while the stars
shine millennia stretched on almost
everyone died except the administrator
thanks to his gift or perhaps curse as
the counterbalance to the black moon
science marched on the scp foundation
marched on but all this progress all
this power was nothing against the
incomprehensible influence of scp-008
the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year 3156 when the foundation
launched the seek project under the
support of project oromastes as more and
more people were wiped out in frequent
obliteration events the administrator
became painfully aware that perhaps the
answers to the black moon problem
wouldn't be found on earth using
state-of-the-art technology with a
little help from the anomalous the scp
foundation began work on an autonomous
space-faring vessel that could search
the stars for the key to the black
moon's destruction it was an
awe-inspiring creation a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence with
a universal translator cryogenic units
and hundreds of autonomous drones to
perform more targeted searches seek was
waved off into the unforgiving depths of
space the administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets seeked arrived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snowstorms when
zeke's drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet seem
to indicate that the black moon was
responsible for the destruction of the
planet's civilization causing so many
obliteration events that the remaining
survivors went mad from the fear and
stress leading to mass death in the
ensuing chaos the next planet was
discovered centuries later in the year
3499
while this planet could also
theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface of flaming mass however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior planet they'd
been driven extinct by black moon
obliteration events a century before the
sikh even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored bat-like creatures
that operated on pure instinct and thus
were not considered conscious enough to
be obliterated the final planet was
reached in 3764
and was the most fruitful of the three
discoveries this planet was hyper
advanced fully urbanized and covered in
sprawling mega-cities with records and
technology over a thousand years ahead
of earth before the black moon killed
almost all of them there were species of
humanoid telepathic fungi and had
developed an awareness of the black
moon's existence that was on par with
that of humanities they even had their
own equivalent of the scp foundation
actively working on countermeasures and
most amazingly of all seek found one
surviving member of the species on the
planet cryogenically frozen the craft
was immediately instructed to collect
the survivor and return home for
interrogation the administrator was
preparing for what could be the most
important conversation since he met the
hermit all those thousands of years ago
does the black moon howl only when
waning when the surviving creature
codenamed saged was returned to earth
the administrator was eager to finally
speak with it like the rest of its now
extinct species sage spoke through
powerful telepathic mind waves which
only the administrator thanks to his
counterbalance abilities was able to
receive at close range without being
harmed incidentally it wasn't long until
the very fact of the administrator's
nature as a counterbalance came up in
the mental conversation sage could tell
just by being in his presence they
discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating that
sage's survival had been pure luck for
starters the black moon is still very
much capable of obliterating conscious
beings in an unconscious state the
administrator also learned that he was
merely the latest in an extremely long
line of counterbalances across time
space and species though everyone but
him had waived this duty passed it on
sage had one question to ask the
administrator in turn what is scb the
singular conceptual bunker being worked
on and perfected for thousands of years
by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual engineers the
administrator replied victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked sage asked him what good victory
would do him then rather than say it
aloud he replied with a thought sage
paused and said i see how blasphemous of
you hopefully it works after this the
administrator proceeded to the singular
conceptual bunker and entered it leaving
instructions for the foundation to be
run by a newly formed 05 council in his
indefinite absence thousands of years
later in the year 5011 sage spoke one
more time repeating the words hopefully
hopefully before turning solid black and
disappearing the black moon had claimed
one more victim but billions more had
gone in the interim the administrator
had no more answers to give at least no
more answers that anyone but him would
understand he was inside the singular
conceptual bunker now loaded into a
device known as tome an experimental
memorial module meant to pick up and
record all the last messages of every
dying civilization across the universe
when the time finally came all he could
do was wait and wait was exactly what we
did does the black moon howl yes
yes it does
years pass too many to count it's a time
after names now and tome sits in the
very center drinking in the end of the
universe the last of all the human
colonies across the universe were
obliterated by the black moon back in
the years 73-29
so so so long ago but some of the final
messages of fear panic and distress
still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here
we require assistance there's it's it's
taking people every day we need help
there's barely anyone left we need help
hello hello
cabal 0943 we have abandoned the false
flesh we have abandoned the false flesh
the shepherd's crook broken neath my
knee cable zero nine four three come on
zero nine four three forgive us forgive
us
we're going to leave this on it's so
dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's i have to go now respond first
convenience emergency
situation developing require additional
resources
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault our fault my fault your fault
awful bring my brain out now rip my
brain out now
and a small child the last on earth
simply asking hello into an indifferent
microphone but the administrator had to
wait as the singular conceptual bunker
became the solitary conceptual bunker he
was the last conscious being in the
universe and still he needed to wait as
the stars went dark outside only when
there was nothing outside but black was
it finally time for the counterbalance's
long game to play off
there was nothing left of our universe
the only thing here was the scb and the
black moon itself with everything else
gone the black moon only had one
conscious being left to obliterate it
opened the door to the solitary
conceptual bunker and stepped inside
this
this doesn't make sense how can the
black moon an entity beyond our
dimension beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance
the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can i pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed to be enjoying himself preparing
for a confrontation hundreds of billions
of years in the making the singular
conceptual bunker or perhaps the
singular containment bunker was a truly
ingenious creation a place of pure ideas
where everything inside was on the same
level here there were no immortals no
gods just ideas on the same level
playing field and it was time for the
black moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and unleashed both
barrels into the black moon's chest the
creature took the hit and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the monster's
relentless assault until he managed to
get his desperate hands on a glass
ashtray he beat the monster over the
head with it until its grip loosened and
he was able to slide out there the
killer of the universe was on the ground
before him he grabbed the monster held
it in place and beat it to death he was
gravely injured by the battle but the
black moon was no more here in the
singular conceptual bunker he had won
the administrator no longer the
counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is
this place is only information
there's nothing else out there not even
matter the universe closed its doors a
long time ago this place can go from
information back to matter with just the
press of a button
let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing for a second it
looks as though he might fall but he
doesn't instead he slams the button on
the jukebox and with a relieve laugh
says
let there be light and there was light
our one
there is only one news story on every
website newspaper and tv screen the
flowers are blooming everywhere all
across the globe every country every
landmass the bitter cold of the
antarctic gives way to a glowing rainbow
of petals the sahara desert and death
valley become beacons of thriving
technicolor plant life the highest
mountains the lowest valleys the darkest
caves the flowers even burst free from
the concrete of cities as if reminding
us that really it was never our world we
were only borrowing it and today
our lease is up this is scp-001
object class unnecessary it was foretold
by tales from other dimensions a distant
future coming down the tracks towards us
and today the train has reached the
station nobody's reporting on how the
economy or the stock market is doing
today no point celebrity scandals have
faded away into nothingness greedy
businessmen lying politicians brutal
tyrants none of them are making the
headlines today the very last headlines
the world gone beautiful and what a
shame it takes the end of it all to make
us realize what really matters to us
that's right you're looking at the end
of the world but it's okay
don't panic take a deep breath in and
out it was bound to happen eventually so
no point worrying now even the
foundation knows that this just isn't
something they can stop so instead of
asking things like how can we prevent
this or do we have any final tricks up
our sleeve let's ask a different
question entirely what would you do if
you knew that you only had 24 hours
until all life on earth ends think hard
after all even if you never live to see
the flowers bloom a final day will still
come for you just as it does for us all
our six a d-class sits alone in the cell
when he sees the flowers growing out of
the ground normally he'd assumed that
this meant he was in some kind of
foundation experiment but not today
everyone on earth had an innate sense
that the time is now a kind of gallows
calm spreads out over everyone and
everything it's over and that's okay we
all knew it was going to happen
eventually right he sighs and gives a
slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps
outside his cell approaching a key
slides into his cell door and opens
there stands dr gears holding a bottle
of wine and two glasses anyone who knows
him might think he's been replaced by
some kind of shape-shifting anomaly or
had his mind taken over by a powerful
cognito hazard but no it's him the
famously cold dr charles ogden gears dr
gears says come on it's a lovely day out
there it'd be a terrible ways to spend
the whole thing cooped up in here it'd
feel like a trick on any day but this
the d-class nods and follows the doctor
out the normally oh so stoic foundation
senior researcher pours himself in the
d-class each a glass of wine and asks
what's your name by the way i don't
think i ever checked the d-class replies
that his name is harold the two smile
and chat as they exit the now empty
d-class containment wing everyone else
is outside already researchers guards
administrative staff and d-classes all
rubbing elbows enjoying the beautiful
sun on their last day together elsewhere
on site a flock of scp-514 is released
just as identical flocks are being
released from every containment site all
over the world they've prepared it all
for this very day
scp-514 is a special breed of homing
pigeons created by the mana charitable
foundation which have the power to
suppress aggression for those within
their field of anomalous influence and
now millions of them are flying all over
the world after all there's no point
fighting on a day like this there is no
future left to secure people always told
them there would forever be hope until
the flowers bloomed no situation was
ever truly over until the world went
beautiful but in the absence of hope
there was something even more inviting
total absolute calm the site-19
personnel sit together and watch the
flowers bloom hour 12. all militaries
call a global ceasefire
soldiers from opposing sides hug and
shake hands in flowery fields that once
seemed choked by death and blood borders
fade bitter rivalries turn to dust korea
unifies all is quiet in the middle east
gangsters and drug cartels drop their
weapons and return home to their
families and friends as flocks of
scp-514 fly above what good is all the
blood money in the world on a day like
this wardens walk sell to cell through
all the world's prisons granting people
their freedom again sometimes after
lifetimes of not having it they taste
the air again feel the sun on their face
they close their eyes drink it in and
walk among the flowers free men
locations of marshall carter and dark
limited close their doors and shutter
their windows worldwide for the first
time in as long as any of them can
remember they turned their signs too
closed they've earned a day off everyone
has the chaos insurgency rolls up their
plans and burns them they drop their
weapons and throw away their tactical
gear as they do so they can't help but
question themselves what was it all for
in the end what was any of it for all
the fighting in bloodshed and death we
did it day after day only to do it again
the next day what silly reasons we
killed and died for what silly reasons
indeed the global cult coalition
dismisses its staff thanking them for
their service and telling them to go
spend their last hours with the ones
they love like the foundation they
accept that this is the one true final
end no ritual to stop no monster to
fight no evil extra dimensional entity
to thwart just go outside and smell the
flowers while you still can the
serpent's hand are similar they decide
after decades fighting a losing battle
they'll spend their last day in the
wanderers library reading some of their
favorite volumes all these wonderful
stories now left for other earths to
read their own stories would be counted
among them in the end and they take
great comfort in that in a sense
everyone will live forever in the pages
of the books in the wanderers library
herman fuller's circus of the
disquieting releases all of its freaks
and clowns from their twisted grasp to
go and live out whatever small dreams
and tiny pleasures they could find over
their last hours they have no foundation
of fear anymore nobody minds their
strange appearances and odd behaviors
why would anyone waste such a beautiful
day judging others on the last day on
earth there's nothing left to prove
sarkicists dropped their ancient
flesh-bound tomes and acolytes of the
broken god put down their gilded blades
on the slopes of siberia the jungles of
peru and the most isolated beaches of
mexico twisted flesh finally touched
living metal in the spirit of husbandry
their eternal war is at its end in the
face of the blooming world they didn't
seem so different after all the agents
of the dr wondertainment corporation
predictably chose to spend their last
hours sitting around and playing with
toys together time well spent if you ask
us in a highly secretive location
perhaps the most heavily secured place
in the entire world the 13 members of
the legendary 05 council decide to just
sit and talk anyone who knows anything
about this secretive cabal can tell you
the o5 council has spent a considerable
portion of their very very long lives
trying to figure out ways to dodge and
cheat death but now facing a death they
can't dodge the same calm washing over
the rest of the world has finally
reached them too all they can really
think this time is well played reaper
well played as they chat about the kind
of inane casual things that they haven't
had time to discuss in years old 5-3
suggests inviting the ethics committee
over to join nobody disagrees hour 16.
it isn't just the d-classes all sapient
and non-aggressive scps have been
released from containment free to spend
the last of their time as they wish tens
of thousands of anomalous individuals
are released from containment sites all
over the globe it'd be the greatest
victory that the serpent's hand could
ever ask for if they weren't all too
busy reading to notice
scp-105 iris thompson finally returns to
her parents the foundation had fed them
the lie that their daughter had died
many years before but as iris had a
tendency to do she was ready to work a
miracle her parents embrace her with
open arms they'll spend their last hours
together catching up on what's happened
since they parted ways and making up for
lost time they couldn't be happier
scp-1867 lord blackwood the fantastical
sea snail is delivered into a warm rock
pool near the site where he was being
contained there he might finally have
one more grand adventure before all is
said and done though afterward he may
not have the time to tell anyone about
it a terrible shame really because
nobody spins a yarn like lord blackwood
the non-aggressive little misters run
free mr fish eagerly returns to his
native boston massachusetts where he
enjoys one more lobster sandwich before
the end of the world mr headless decides
to go hat shopping because he wants to
look good for the apocalypse mr lost
finally settles down for the afternoon
deciding that just this once he's earned
himself a rest
scp-2800 cactus men returns to edinburgh
to spend his last days picking up litter
and helping old ladies cross the street
scp-3663 the tunnel monster walks the
streets of his hometown searching for an
old friend
hoping to reunite before it all ends
scp-073-kane decides to take a walk
outside for the first time in thousands
of years he can't help but smile as the
bright colorful life beneath his feet is
growing faster than his presence can
kill it what a truly beautiful day
knowing that there's no longer time for
colts to form and bother him
scp-2662 cthulhu decides to take a break
from his intense minecraft session and
go take a walk outside it feels so good
to have the sun on his tentacles once
more and to feel the lush green grass
under his suction cups he shakes his
head thinking once again about the
irritating cults that had been pestering
him for decades what kind of idiot would
want him to destroy a world like this
scp-343 also known as god sighs and
looks over all his creation for what he
knows to be the last time his mouth
curls into a smile as he thinks well we
had a pretty good run still in a cell
scp-049 the plague doctor puts his feet
up and decides to relax the pestilence
will soon be taken care of on some
animalistic level below thought below
even instinct
scp-096 feels grateful that no gaze will
ever fall upon it again
somewhere fizzling in a vat of acid
within a highly secure containment
chamber
scp-682 is feeling for the first time in
its hellish existence a sense of
profound relief the pain
the hate the rage the constant
termination attempts it all be over soon
hour 23 people gather in the streets
they laugh and dance and sing as the
moon shines
fat and white far above deep in their
hearts they quietly contemplate the end
of all of this but why worry why spoil
the fun there's no future left to worry
about strangers become as close as
family in the end human or otherwise
anomalous or non-anomalous chaos
insurgency agents have last suppers with
ex-serpent's hands and goc operatives
there is no hate left no violence no
malice no cruelty the greatest tragedy
in all of this is that it took the
ultimate end to bring it out in people
but why worry why worry seconds pass
then minutes the world buzzes it hums
trillions of creatures doing everything
they'd wanted even though it won't last
in the face of the true end the world
has never been more alive hour 24
silence forever and ever and ever good
night we'll end this video the way it
began by putting a question to you how
would you spend your last 24 hours on
earth let us know down in the comments
because it'll happen to all of us
eventually for decades upon decades
conspiracy theories have long captured
the minds of many individuals and groups
across the world the infamous ones will
always spring to mind the moment
somebody so much as speaks the phrase
conspiracy theory aloud the words alone
conjure up questions like were the moon
landings really faked did aliens really
have a hand in building the pyramids and
is there really a shadowy ancient order
called the illuminati controlling the
events of the world around us of course
the answer to all of these questions is
often a plain and resounding no now
please leave me alone but delving into
the world of conspiracy theories
collecting and connecting evidence can
be an interesting exercise in
imagination when it's all done in good
fun but there is often a dangerous side
to conspiracy theories as well and we
don't mean getting so close to the truth
that the men in black show up to your
front door and haul you away to area 51.
now it's important to remember the harm
that some conspiracy theories can do
it's an unfortunate truth that a number
of conspiracy theories especially those
more prevalent in recent years are often
used to unjustly villainize particular
religious or ethnic minorities posting
about ancient aliens can be fun when you
remember that conspiracy theories have
no actual bearing on the real world but
the line has to be drawn somewhere the
minute a theory starts to delve into
unseemly territory it's best to realize
that there is very little truth to it
there is one infamous conspiracy theory
not a vindictive or harmful one that has
stood the test of time for almost as
long as the moon landings or area 51.
who really killed president john f
kennedy we all know or think we know
what really happened on november 22nd
1963 on that fateful day in dallas texas
but what if that's the point we all
think we know but each of us thinks
differently grab your red string and
shiniest tinfoil hats and take a seat
folks welcome to
scp-001 otherwise known by the
appropriate nickname the conspiracy now
first things first some important
information anyone familiar with the scp
foundation will tell you that there are
multiple entities and objects referred
to as
scp-001 everyone has some idea which of
these they think is the real one but
just in case you happen to be new here
will clarify for you the designation
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity within the
foundation's archive instead it's a
collection of various anomalies that
have been encountered and mostly
contained by the scp foundation as for
why these various files are all
collected under this shared designation
well that's a conspiracy theory all in
itself it could be that these anomalies
are some of the earliest ever contained
by the foundation and were first
encountered before they had established
the numbering system that they currently
use however could these multiple
scp-001s be an intentional misdirection
smells like another conspiracy to us
among the anomalies sharing the title of
scp-001
is the gate guardian a powerful being
believed to be an angel standing at the
entrance to the garden of eden then
there's the infamous scarlet king
another anomalous eldritch creature with
similar levels of destructive power who
is intent on one day causing the
destruction of all creation also known
as scp-001 is a database containing all
of the proof the foundation's top brass
has collected that prove their entire
universe is the fictional creation of
the scp wiki authors pretty wild stuff
and then there's this scp-001
the conspiracy itself as we mentioned
before it's connected to the
assassination of united states president
john f kennedy very closely connected at
least for a few seconds before it came
out on the other side that is because in
this instance scp-001
is the bullet that killed jfk now
history tells us that on friday november
22nd 1969 the 35th president of the
united states john fitzgerald kennedy
was riding in an open top car as part of
a presidential motorcade traveling
through daley plaza in dallas texas a
former u.s marine named lee harvey
oswald opened fire on the president
through the window of a nearby building
tragically killing jfk but ever since
kennedy's death there have been rampart
speculation about what really happened
in dallas most theories suggest that
there was a secret organization involved
or multiple shooters in addition to lee
harvey oswald according to the
foundation through some anomalous means
the shot that killed john f kennedy was
fired by multiple unidentified
assailants acting as a part of the same
or numerous conspiracies all shooting at
the exact same moment the events
surrounding the bullet's trajectory are
designated under the code name incident
001 gamma anyone alive that has memories
linked to incident 001 gamma is part of
the last population on planet earth that
can agree on a shared concept of truth
they know what is true thanks to all
sharing and experience of either hearing
about the kennedy assassination or
witnessing it in person or on television
when scp-001 was fired it created
incident 001 gamma which was both a
pivotal moment in history and also had a
lasting effect on everything that
followed it might not be obvious how
just yet but we'll get to the
repercussions in a moment the fact that
multiple generations alive at the time
of incident 001 gamma have a consistent
memory of it establishes a baseline
essentially because these people have
vivid memories of the assassination they
also have a societal memory of
everything that had occurred in human
history up until that day in 1969.
the evolution of mankind the various
wars that had occurred had all been
documented and were held to be true
there was a shared collective truth
among earth's entire population up until
incident zero zero one gamma occurred
however reality had shattered in some
way the moment that
scp-001 was shot towards jfk the sheer
number of conspiracy theories that
tumbled out of the kennedy assassination
weren't just rampart speculation not
only did everyone on earth now have a
memory of what happened they had their
own version of what they believed they
had remembered for example from the
moment that incident 001 gamma took
place and jfk was shot there were
already conflicting witness testimonies
from people who were actually present in
dallas and saw it all happen a
significant percentage of eyewitnesses
reported some variation of seeing a
strange unidentified figure referred to
only as badge man whoever he was even if
he was just a result of civilians being
unfamiliar with seeing secret service
agents not everyone that was present at
incident zero zero one gamma can agree
if badge man was even there at all the
only two people that were definitely
participants in the assassination were
president kennedy and lee harvey oswald
history diverged for everyone from that
point on remembering everything that
came before but having conflicting
memories of incident zero zero one gamma
and everything that followed it what the
scp foundation knows for a fact is that
lee harvey oswald fired three shots from
his vantage point on the sixth floor of
the texas school book depository the
first missed the second delivered a
wound to the president as well as texas
governor john connolly who was riding in
the same car as jfk the third and final
shot was scp-001
which vaporized the cranial cavity
killing him and causing incident 001
gamma
from that moment on there now existed a
confusing and contradictory number of
different perspectives on the world's
history all conflicting with one another
people's perceptions began to divert
away from reality over the course of the
next decade slowly and unnoticeably at
first everyone could still agree on what
had happened since incident 001 gamma
for the most part until september 5th
1975
the failed assassination of gerald ford
the 38th president of the united states
multiple witnesses reported seeing
different versions of the event some
even certain that president ford was in
fact killed this even resulted in
another attempt on ford's life only two
weeks later by a woman who believed the
president was already dead attempting to
make reality aligned with what she
thought to be real but it gets worse
president ford had equally been affected
by scp-001
believing that the soviet union had
withdrawn from eastern europe during the
nixon administration in reality this
didn't occur until the late 1980s
that is the true effect of scp-001
the disparity between what someone
perceives to be real and what is
actually real it can often manifest in
frustration we've all once felt that we
have the skills required when applying
for a job only to have a rejection email
sent back to us some of us believe
ourselves to be kind good-hearted people
it can't seem to find any friend that
would agree living in a huge house can
make a person feel cramped and
claustrophobic despite all the space
around them you can feel that there is
something wrong in situations like this
but you can't explain it this effect of
scp-001 can often result in conditions
like imposter syndrome where someone has
the belief that all of their
achievements and successes are nothing
more than a sham and that the best parts
of their lives are destined to fall
apart because that person does not
deserve them that feeling of not
belonging the world not aligning with
what you think is true all comes from
scp-001 the phenomenon known as the
mandela effect is also seemingly derived
from the fractalization that occurred
after incident 001 gamma the mandela
effect usually refers to a memory held
by an individual or group of individuals
that they believe to be true but
actually differs from fact for example
the effect is named after nelson mandela
who died in 2013 however countless
people distinctly remember news that
mandela had died in prison during the
80s misremembering history comes as a
result of a person's perception and
their living memory being out of sync
with that which is true often trying to
undo the effects of scp-001 can be more
harmful to a person as having their
perception vary so dramatically from
reality say you believe that all the
beatles were still alive you were
positive of it and it had always been
that way all of your life then somebody
presented you with actual historical
proof that john lennon was killed
outside his hotel in the year 1980. all
the photographs news reports and other
evidence in the world couldn't convince
you that what you thought to be true in
fact wasn't frequently this leads to
frustration and confusion that could and
often does damage relationships with
friends and family causing isolation and
disconnection of social associations if
everyone is telling you that john lennon
died but you can't believe it because it
doesn't match your own perception you
would gravitate towards people whose
alternate viewpoints overlapped with
yours this is how echo chambers form
which spread and strengthen conspiracy
theories often making them more
resilient against outside logic as well
as more extreme and pernicious so who
really did kill president john f kennedy
ask lee harvey oswald he'd say he didn't
do it and was instead being framed ask
fidel castro and he'd tell you that he
and his men were there in dallas that
day armed and on a mission to kill
kennedy themselves or there's the
umbrella man who claimed he killed jfk
with a modified umbrella but ultimately
speculating as to who killed president
kennedy is pointless every answer is
right to someone
scp-001 was the shot that changed the
entire world since incident zero zero
one gamma nobody has been able to
perceive the world in the exact same way
as someone else does if you feel
confused rely on what you know to be
real what you believe is the truth and
find comfort in the normalcy of that
honestly it's all you really have
at the time of this video's writing the
scp foundation currently contains well
over 6 000 items this organization
really gets around from making deals
with deities to containing horrors
capable of ending the world in a
heartbeat so it's hard to think of this
secret group ever having humble
beginnings but everyone and everything
has to start somewhere right and would
you believe that one of the most
powerful groups in the world all started
with a little sheaf of papers of course
that's if this particular iteration of
scp-001
is to be believed that's right we once
again return to scp-001
the gift that keeps on taking it is a
heavily contested spot currently held by
over 30 different contradictory
anomalies and counting their natures
vary from things that started the
foundation to things more than capable
of ending it along with the rest of the
world and everything in between the
scarlet king the gate guardian and the
ever eccentric dr wondertainment all
exist under this banner but today we
want to talk about a little stack of
paper bound by a single staple in the
top left corner who would have guessed
that something this simple would not
only be pivotal in the creation of the
scp foundation as we know it today but
could also be one of the most dangerous
items ever discovered we realize this is
a lot to take in keeping with the
scp-001 spirit let's take it all the way
back to the beginning to the fine oak
desk of the late
um
oh
we don't have a name shame
let's just call him the first
administrator he's the head honcho of
the precursor to the foundation as we
know it today a rinky dink little
organization with the thankless task of
keeping the paranormal under wraps we're
talking a long long time ago here no
lanky freaks who kill everybody who sees
their face no gloopy sadists who can
walk through walls no giant unkillable
reptiles with major anger issues this
organization let's call them the
precursors was dealing with the real
small fries paranoiacs reporting ghost
sightings in their garden sheds old
ladies finding the face of jesus in a
piece of toast abnormally large and
strangely shaped potato chips okay maybe
not that small time but you get the idea
truly exceptional anomalies were few and
far between until the sheaf of papers
landed on the dearly deceased
administrator's desk he didn't even know
how exactly the papers got there but
given the number of mostly junk files
that passed his desk every day he wasn't
in the business of questioning the words
confidential report on special items
classified were printed on the front
this made it more interesting than
ninety percent of the files he read on a
daily basis already so he turned the
first page and began to read it was much
stranger than the usual paranormal
reports that the precursor foundation
processed no late night whaling or
rattling chains instead it was a
surprisingly sterile report about a
bizarre and frightening anomaly a large
fleshy tumor-like object fixed to a set
of metal stairs inside the object is a
seemingly normal living room but on
closer inspection all the furniture is
made out of living human tissue and
flesh anyone who steps inside is
transformed into more nightmarish living
furniture the administrator gave a
nervous chuckle it was disturbing sure
but stephen king wrote about disturbing
things all the time and that didn't mean
that the foundation needed to be on the
lookout for an evil clown well until
scp-993 the sinister bobble the clown
would enter the foundation's radar a few
years later that's a video for another
time the administrator put the file into
his incredibly disorganized filing
cabinet and prepared to go home and
drink bourbon until he fell asleep
that's exactly when his office phone
began to ring when the administrator
picked up the phone he heard the excited
voice of one of his field agents telling
him they just scored the find of the
century a giant sphere made from living
flesh with a room inside finally an
honest-to-god terrifying paranormal
anomaly he could hardly believe what he
was hearing he needed to grab and reread
the file just to make sure he wasn't
going insane where exactly did he put it
he scrambled through the filing cabinet
tossing aside the files on shed ghosts
and burnt toast jesus's until he found
the file marked confidential report on
special items classified however when he
opened the file there was nothing about
the giant fleshy room in there it must
have been a completely different file
that he'd somehow missed before because
this one was about something known as
the biological motherboard the document
detailed pretty much exactly what the
name suggested a large and incredibly
complex motherboard made out of
biological material like keratin and
chitin while the motherboard would
remain inactive if kept warm if its
environment ever fell below 35 degrees
it would begin to expand integrating
nearby material into its mass and
attempting to copy the structure of any
biological matter it comes into contact
with an interesting and frightening
prospect but not what he was looking for
he threw this new file down onto his
desk and continued to work through his
chaotic filing cabinet like a madman
searching for the file on that
frightening fleshy room that his
subordinates had seemingly actually
discovered but not long after that he
received another phone call from a
completely different field agent this
time the agent was giddily telling the
administrator about a new discovery a
huge computer motherboard seemingly made
out of entirely organic material the
administrator was floored he hung up the
phone and slowly turned back to the file
now laying on his desk those words on
the cover confidential report on special
items classified seemed almost mocking
now had all these incredible
supernatural anomalies been reported
before and just lost in his awful filing
cabinet was he one of the most
incompetent team leaders who'd ever
walked the earth just what exactly was
going on here he sat back down at his
desk now fantasizing about the tumbler
of bourbon more than ever and open the
file again hoping to read up a little
more on the impossible motherboard that
his personnel had just discovered but
there was nothing about the biological
motherboard on these pages instead it
described a large door inside a factory
and the 12 rusty keys capable of opening
it each of these keys would open the
doorway but the key used would affect
the reality waiting for them on the
other side only the 7th and 12th keys
were safe opening the door with any of
the others would lead to a horrible
death for anyone brave or foolish enough
to walk through several days later an
anomaly matching that exact description
was discovered and contained by the
foundation all of this had been an
unprecedented escalation of anomalous
stakes suddenly two crucial facts
clicked into place for the administrator
firstly this file was an anomalous
supernatural artifact of its own
secondly the reason it was never the
same thing was that this strange sheaf
of papers had a very specific purpose to
act as a kind of oracle an advanced
warning system of the next anomaly that
would appear and fall into their grasp
giving them all the knowledge and tools
they needed to safely lock these things
away the whole thing had been timed
perfectly what a miracle that this
immensely useful item would appear in
his office just as the anomalies would
start to come in thick and fast it would
facilitate their mission in the coming
struggles to secure contain and protect
the world's anomalies hmm
there's a certain ring to that isn't
there they were finding enough anomalies
to start classifying them numerically
starting with the sheaf of papers
themselves as scp-001
with another turn of the page the
administrator discovered a file on a
magical key that can open any lock not
long after that exact key was discovered
and brought in before being designated
scp-005
little by little as more real anomalies
came in the organization was able to
expand and bring in more personnel as
well as bring in more sources of funding
and opening new sites the rate this
organization was expanding they couldn't
even leave management up to one person
anymore they needed to form a whole
council to take over management n05
council if you will and it just so
happened that just after that the sheaf
of papers revealed a mythical spring
that could provide eternal health and
vitality for anyone who drinks from it
what a perfect way to keep your
management safe in a job dealing with
dangerous supernatural entities and
things only got stranger and more
fascinating from there after that came a
man with a miniature version of the
planet earth inside his abdomen soon
known as
scp-007 next came a horrifying virus
that kills and reanimates its victims
into flesh-eating zombies only capable
of being destroyed with sufficient
trauma to the head dubbed
scp-008 after containment another turn
of the page and not long after a
frightening red ice was discovered in
alaska this mysterious substance breaks
the laws of physics and also has the
potential to break all life on earth it
can infect water supplies and when a
hapless lifeform happens to drink this
water their organs crystallized from the
inside this became
scp-009 another turn of the page and
this new scp foundation found a
collection of six metal collars created
for human size necks when these collars
are placed around the necks of a victim
the person holding a corresponding
controller has utter domination over
their every action it carried on like
that hundreds of anomalies and then
thousands years passed the staff changed
the old guard stepped down or died every
time the sheaf of papers were opened new
astonishing premonitions of anomaly soon
to be discovered slipped through there
were plague doctors who could kill with
a touch a giant angel with bladed wings
a sea snail that believed he was an
english lord a sculpture that would kill
anyone that dared to stop looking at it
a nightmarish fusion of a giant bovine
heart and a scorpion capable of setting
things on fire with its venom whatever
would the scp foundation have done
without the advanced warning system
provided by the sheaf of papers whatever
it predicted would inevitably be the
next thing foundation field agents would
find it seems like one of the few
unambiguously good scp-001 entries out
there right well not quite if we have
any scientists in the audience they've
no doubt been gritting their teeth and
pulling their hair out in frustration
allow us to introduce you to a little
phrase that the latest iteration of the
o5 council is very interested in when it
comes to the sheaf of papers
direction of causality this whole time
we in the earlier foundation
administrators believe that the
emergence of the new anomalies led to
changes in scp-001
but this current administration has
quite the opposite question what if the
changes in scp-001
were actually causing the emergence of
new anomalies what if every time the
prior administration opened up the sheaf
of papers to take a look at the next
anomaly before giving themselves a pat
on the back for being so well prepared
they were actually unleashing that very
anomaly could it be that what had seemed
like the most helpful item of the bunch
was actually the most dangerous of them
all releasing new anomaly after new
anomaly blighting the world with
countless horrors that probably leaves
you with one question
so which is correct is it a method of
seeing the future or manipulating it and
our answer is a strong
we don't know but frankly the current
leadership of the scp foundation sees no
merit in taking that risk that's why the
chief of papers has been given the keter
class designation and is kept under
extensive and severe containment methods
forbidding any future research into the
true nature of its anomalous abilities
seems a little severe sure but better
safe than sorry right now go check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
and
scp-001 oroboro cycle the story
compilation for more of the fascinating
and endless mystery of scp-001